- Yo what's up fam,
we just hit 5,000 subs.
(Garnt laughing)
I think we can get 6,000 if
you really liked this show.
If you liked this video,
don't forget to comment, like, subscribe,
'cause today, we're gonna be reviewing
the windows installer.
(music mimics)
- What's up Mike Wazowski enthusiast?
Welcome back to another
episode of Trash Taste.
- My favorite, Mike Wazowski.
- Yeah, you're all Mike
Wazowski enthusiasts.
I'm your host, Joey
and with me is Garnt and Connor.
You know who we are.
- Wow, that was just like,
let's just jump right into it.
- No wasting time. You
guys know who we are.
We're fucking, how many episodes?
25 at this point, 26?
- Don't remind me man.
- I don't even know.
- It's just 25 I believe.
- I saw a brilliant comment,
I think it was on episode
21 or 22 or something-
- Right.
- That said...
The top comment was like,
"How has it already been 22 episodes?
It still feels like episode four."
- No, I totally agree.
I can't remember how
many episodes it was ago
where I was like, "Yeah,
were just like a month
into this really."
- Yeah.
- And it was like episode 18 or something.
(hosts laughing)
- Yeah, I remember you said that was like
that math don't add up.
(hosts laughing)
- 18 Weeks in a month, you know?
That's what it felt like this year.
Fucking hell.
- Oh my God!
- Yeah, but what are we
gonna talk about today lads?
- Well, this is the YouTuber episode,
so we're gonna discuss some
of our favorite Youtubers
and just generally discuss
Youtubers that we watch
and the ones that we wanna talk about.
- Basically we just simping
over other content creators.
- Your favorite Youtuber's
favorite Youtuber.
Who is it?
(Garnt laughing)
Who is it gonna be?
- Still wanna bear in mind
that we've said this before,
but sometimes people forget it.
They have to come here
to be on the podcast,
no exceptions.
- I love all the comments that are like,
"But they have a TV?
You can just get them on a Skype call."
- The thing about this,
we can talk about the Calli episode now,
cause that's out.
- Now that's it's out.
- And all the speculation
that they were like,
"Oh yeah, she's just gonna
appear on the TV, right?"
- And then we just fucking dunk on them
and be like, "JK, she's right here."
- Calli was indeed there.
- Oh yeah, I don't know
if we actually prefaced
in that episode because it's
been like what, four weeks.
As of us recording this
then it came out, but, yeah.
For people who are wondering,
she was physically sitting
right here as well.
- Calli that is.
- Calli was, yes.
- Yeah.
- Meilyne he looking at me it's like I...
We signed an NDA.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, we just want to preference that,
like she was actually here.
- Yeah, we can say we
signed an NDA, right?
Okay, we signed an NDA.
- I think it's pretty obvious
that we would have had to sign an NDA.
- Is there an NDA on us signing an NDA?
(hosts laughing)
- I just wanna make sure
what's the NDA level?
How many NDAs do you (indistinct)
(hosts laughing)
- We can't disclose that
we've signed an NDA.
- [Meilyne] You can't
say how it was filmed.
- You can't say how it was done,
but you guys know how it was done.
It's pretty obvious how it was done.
- Yeah, we did it.
(Garnt laughing)
We did it, we nailed it.
- But I've had two hell
weeks back to back.
- Man, you have had the worst
fucking experience on YouTube.
- I know. Since this is
a YouTube related thing,
so we will jump into the
Youtubers after this,
but-
- Yeah.
- So on the convention
horror story episode,
which is episode 23 I believe.
- 22.
- Was it 22?
- Yes.
- Oh, wow!
Okay, well that-
- I don't remember the episode numbers.
- Well, that episode we recorded.
I spoke about getting
hired to do the Samsung ad,
and were like, "He-he that's
funny, I got undercharged."
Turned out it was not he-he funny
because the company fucking
struck my video down.
(Garnt laughing)
And it was just, oh my God!
It was almost worst that
they replied to our emails.
- Yeah.
- Because normally you just, if it's Sony
or it's a giant music company-
- To explain, they contents
claimed your video,
am I correct?
So they gave you a copyright strike.
They copystriked your video, right?
- And we copystriked Sea Dogs in the ad.
- And normally, like as a Youtuber,
especially when you've done like from...
Especially someone in my position
if you just used anime footage,
copyright strikes aren't
anything new for me.
But the normal thing I do
is like reply to them being like,
"Hey, this is fair use and everything."
And 90% of the time,
they just don't reply.
- Yeah.
- Because they're Japanese companies,
they don't give a shit.
So I've never dealt with
a copystrike situation-
- Were they have replied.
- Where they've just back to back.
- I'm actually...
(Garnt laugh)
- I almost wished they didn't,
because like, "Oh my God!"
- It must be hell.
- It was like this...
I've never had a more rude company.
- Yeah.
- And I don't expect
them to be nice to me,
'cause they don't owe me anything.
But just being polite would be nice.
- You've had some seriously
bad luck with (indistinct).
I mean like the whole ultra-
- All of my videos have
been claimed twice,
so I lost a lot of money on that.
And then this one obviously happened.
But this one was just frustrating
because they hired me.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- So the ad that I'm voicing
in, they struck me for it.
(Garnt laughing)
And that reasoning was
because I showed the footage
and in my Fiverr gig that
where they hired me, right?
So the video was for,
for people who don't know,
I was doing a video where
it was a Fiverr seller
and I was a voice actor, and
on my Fiverr gig I said like,
"Hey, anything you order
will be used in the video."
- Right.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I was like, "Hey man, you guys know
that I was gonna use this.
One, you should have told me.
Can you at least give me the..."
'Cause this was
misunderstanding and whatever.
Give me a chance to remove the footage,
because on YouTube you can
actually edit the video live,
so you can actually remove stuff.
'Cause we we'll.
- Yeah.
- We all know this, right?
So I was saying like, "Hey,
just remove this strike,
it takes one button
and I'll get rid of the
copyright stuff right away."
- All right, right.
- Like clearly this is not a big deal,
let's just sort this out.
And their response was
like, "We're too busy."
(Garnt laughing)
And bear in mind, it is one button.
It is one button to
remove the strike, right?
- But it's the button
that's just so far away.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- They replied with
something along the lines of,
"We have so many projects going
on, we're extremely busy."
Bear in mind, our email chain
is like 20 fucking emails.
We've got a huge...
This is bullshit.
- As if you're not busy.
- It was less buttons to claim
the video in the first place.
(Joey laughing)
Like what the hell?
- And I told in the email, I'm like,
"You could have emailed me,
I would have removed it ASAP."
And they're like, "Well
we don't know that.
We didn't wanna deal with
talking and all that."
- 'Cause there like, to explain,
there are several levels
of copyright strike, right?
You can just claim the content
and give the content
creators zero strikes.
And then if you do that,
then they can edit out
the copywrited material,
and-
- Which I would have done.
- Yeah, which he would have done.
No, but they went like the nuclear option.
They just straight up gave you a strike,
put a strike in your account-
- Took the video down.
- Took the video down,
and so you have zero
control over the video.
To explain to people.
- Yeah.
And a strike is, I mean,
I'm sure you all know this,
but three strikes and your channel's gone,
of copyright strikes.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- And I explained that to them
and they were like, "Well
you know, not our problem."
And I was like, "Well, I mean, kinda is,
'cause you're the one who did this.
And you know, it doesn't
really need to be this way
and it's very easy to fix."
And they just kept saying,
"Well, we don't really care."
And it was just awful, just awful.
And fuck, what else happened?
God, I might have cussing
while I think about the story.
(Joey and Garnt giggle)
- I remember you politely saying,
but you know, "Hey,
I probably need to talk
about this on my channel."
- Yes so, I told them, "Hey..."
Because they were just
being so uncooperative
and they were even fine with
the idea of me editing it out,
But they kept saying, "hey,
just ask YouTube to do it.
Just ask YouTube."
The problem is right,
is that YouTube, as it should be,
isn't involved with it. It
doesn't involve with this issue.
- Yeah, it's just a mediator.
- They're just the ones who host it,
it's not their problem.
They kept saying, "We've
gone through YouTube,
so why are you contacting us?
Go through YouTube's system."
And I don't think they understood
that YouTube tells you to contact them,
because it's not their problem.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- YouTube is like, you
have to talk to them.
So that's what we're trying to tell them.
It's like talking to a fucking wall
'cause they are like,
they just don't get it.
I don't think they understand
YouTube's system so well.
- Not only do they not get
it, but it's frustrating
because they don't care to understand it.
- They don't care to
understand, they don't get it,
because they've got their result,
which is the video down.
- Exactly.
- And then you know, after every...
We sent like 10 emails back and forth.
I think maybe it even caught them up
and they kinda like shrugged it off.
So nothing's happening.
So in the email we write saying,
"Hey, well, I hate to say this,
but we're probably gonna
have to re upload the video,
which I am doing,
and we're probably gonna have
to explain in that video,
why it's been taken down,
which may make you look bad."
And they immediately responded with like,
"How dare you try and blackmail us?"
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It was like, "We will not entertain
nor give in to blackmail."
I'm like, "What are you,
the US government
dealing with terrorists?"
- We will not negotiate with terrorists.
(hosts laughing)
- That was literally
the vibe of this email.
It was so funny.
- We will not take this slander.
- They went full fucking Karen mode, man.
They're like, "I am the victim actually.
How dare you come to my house
and you threaten me?"
- That's literally the...
They literally did the full 180.
- [Meilyne] They said
"We will never give in".
(hosts laughing)
- We will never give in.
- [Garnt And Connor]
We will never give in.
- We will never give in.
Okay actually, guess which
country this company is from?
I think it will make so much sense.
- I don't know.
- Just take a guess.
What country do you think
is super strict with rules?
(sighs)
Top of your head.
- I would think in some
kind of Asian country.
- No, European.
- Russia?
- No, Germany.
- Oh, okay.
(Garnt laughing)
- We're following the rules.
(imitating German accent)
- That makes sense, yeah.
- And I tried so many routes.
Like trying to get this
done through YouTube.
I have even the company saying like,
"Hey, they don't care that..."
They are totally fine
with me getting the stuff
removed from the video
and re uploading it,
but they just don't want to do that.
They don't want to remove the strike.
And so as also, I asked Fiverr,
I said, "Hey Fiverr, I know
that I did use that footage
and it's up in the air
and if it's fair use
or not, whatever, et cetera, et cetera."
Fiverr, even though I was
critical of them in that video,
I did say that I think it's
wrong if Fiverr takes...
Fiverr takes a bit of the tips,
which I don't think they should do.
- [Garnt And Joey] Right.
- And they also charge 20% on everything.
And Fiverr actually reached
out on my behalf to the company
and asked, "Hey, we
know this is a problem,
but hey, could you please
put the video back up?"
- Oh, so Fiverr had your back?
- Fiverr backed me up.
- Oh nice!
- You know what they told Fiverr?
- [Garnt And Joey] What?
(Connor laughing)
- They said to Fiverr,
"We wanna keep the strike on his channel
'cause he tried to blackmail us.
(Garnt laughing)
That's what they told Fiverr.
No joke, that's what they told.
- Oh my God!
- This company was just so
petty the whole way through.
It was so tragic.
And so now I'm just re uploading the video
and just explaining that.
- So do you still have a strike?
- Still have the strike
unfortunately, they won't remove it.
- But at least you're gonna
slightly call them out right,
in the video?
- [Garnt] Yeah, I mean, you know-
- You're probably not
gonna say them by name
but still-
- I mean it's...
If you look through the video,
then you can see the name of the company,
at least it's there.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Exactly.
- I feel like, I dunno...
Because the way I've
been conditioned as...
The way I was taught as a kid
was to get problems resolved.
It's polite, you know, to ask politely
and to resolve conflicts in adult manner.
- Yeah, be civil about it, right?
- Yeah be civil about it.
But the more I'm on the internet
and the more, especially as a Youtuber,
I've realized that to get problems solved
and to get shit done,
it goes against everything
I was taught, because...
- They're the best way
to get shit resolved
is just go out into the
public and go, "Fuck you".
(hosts laughing)
- It's true though, right?
Because we've been conditioned
now to get a problem resolved
is to make as much fucking noise possible.
- Hey fanbase, I'm gonna give
you a new target to go off.
Seek em.
- Yeah.
- It's unfortunate, because
I always as a last resort,
tweet about it or make it a public issue.
Because I just don't like it.
I think it's really-
- Because there's a part of
you that makes you look bad.
- I feel like an asshole being like,
"Yo, but I got this following,
I'ma set the dogs on this one.
(hosts laughing)
- Release the hounds.
It feels like that's the
only way to get things done,
especially when it's like...
I love the fact that the official way
to get problems resolved on YouTube,
is just to fucking at
team YouTube on Twitter
and just get people to retweet that,
instead of having a proper
chain of communication.
No, you just got to make
as much fucking noise
on Twitter as possible.
- It's not a last resort
to at team YouTube,
it's just a requirement.
- If it's a YouTube problem,
I'll at team YouTube.
But this shit was kind of that company,
and honestly their social media...
I found their social
media isn't everything,
they're pretty small.
If I wanted to make them
known, I could have tweeted out
and be like, "Hey guys,
go and fucking spam
their social media ask
them to remove the strike."
But I don't know, I just
didn't wanna do that.
- You don't wanna use your
power for that kind of stuff.
- It's sad as well,
'cause I could do that,
and that would be like,
I guess I'm using my power, right?
But then also the only reason
they aren't taking me seriously
is because I'm an individual.
- Yeah, exactly,
- [Joey] right, right.
- And it's unfair
because they're a company
and they think that I'm just a fly,
and that they can just
swat me away every time,
which they just kept doing.
And yeah, at any point I
could have just made...
The thing is, right, is that
you don't want to say it,
but if people search
for the company's name,
you could easily make it,
so that the stuff that comes
up is pretty bad for them.
(Connor laughing) Could
have easily have done that,
but I'm not going to,
cause I'm not an asshole.
- You might be a flyer,
but you're a flyer that's
about six feet long.
(Garnt laughing)
It's gonna be a little
hard to swat you away.
- It's like such a
thing, 'cause it's like,
"Man, I really wanna
abuse my power right now."
(Connor laughing)
- Go on a power trip.
- I really wanna thoroughly
abuse my power right now
and make your life hell
because you guys are
being absolute assholes.
- Cigar in one hand,
(Garnt laughing)
let's get them.
- It's like trying to find a
right balance between like...
I got my integrity, you know,
I wanna be a good person,
but at the same time,
it's just the world is making it
super fucking hard sometimes.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- And it fucking sucks
that it's this way, but...
- I mean, it's just that war between
the traditionalist way of doing things
and then the new age things of doing that.
Because, you know, even
if YouTube right now
is such a massive thing worldwide,
technically speaking, it's
only been around for what?
15 years?
- Yeah.
I mean, it's just, I feel like
it's just the age of social media now
where it is all about making
as much noise as possible,
even if you are someone
very much in the wrong,
and your logic is fucked,
- Yeah.
- Somehow some people are
able to make more noise
than the other person,
therefore they are the right ones,
that they win in the end.
- Yeah.
- And it's a very, I
would say backwards way,
but it's just the way the
world is now unfortunately.
- I think it's just the
hands that we've been dealt.
Unfortunately with YouTube system,
it's really sad that it only ever gives
any benefit to the claimant.
So it's like you kind of
don't really have a choice,
and it sucks because people
who don't wanna do it...
I mean I don't want to do it,
I don't want to make a
fuss about it on Twitter.
And I probably might've
been able to get it resolved
if I just made it hell for them.
If I just bombed their
social medias and just-
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- It might've worked,
but did I want to find out
and would I felt good about it?
Like probably not.
- You don't wanna resort to that, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, It's horrible.
- 'Cause the thing about,
especially with YouTube copyright,
is that there's just been...
Everything that's been mentioned
and everything that people
say is all fucking guesswork.
Because the thing is,
there is no precedence,
because the highest
level this can go up to
it's like-
- Supreme court?
- It's like court right?
And that's only happened
once between one creator
and one creator, which is like H3H3.
- Yeah.
- And that's been the only precedence
about anything regarding
YouTube copyright.
We've never had an individual
go up against the company.
So nobody knows how that's
gonna end up really.
- I think because the company
doesn't really want that
'cause it'll look bad for them.
- And no individual wants to be the test.
- Yeah, exactly, nobody
wants to be the first.
- Do you really wanna
be that company picking
on a singular dude?
And then that dude also rally
the internet behind him?
You probably don't want that.
You might win it,
but everyone will think you're an asshole.
- In that situation,
kind of everyone loses.
There is no single winner at that point.
- No.
- Maybe the creator can come out of it
if he's willing to go through it.
The creator might come
out with a lot of respect
and might get a lot of
community support and yeah,
it could be worth it, but
it's such a big gamble.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- It could also completely
go the other way around.
just ruin your life.
- It could bankrupt you.
- It can not only
bankrupt that individual,
but it could also leave an
example for other companies
to start abusing that, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- It's like, "Oh well, they
lost it in the court case,
so let's go out and
just fucking snipe down
all these individual creatives."
- Yeah, 'cause fucking,
nobody fucking understands the law anyway.
None of us really
understand fair use laws.
How the fuck are the fucking jury
gonna understand fair use laws?
You know what I mean?
- So what, you used anime
ghoul in your video,
and this company owns said anime ghoul,
but doesn't actually own it.
- Yeah.
- It's like, yes, your honor.
(hosts laughing)
- Geez, I have to mask even
how world wide YouTube is.
How do you sue someone
that's in a different country
with different laws?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- What if none of you
are an American company,
which laws are you using?
You're using YouTube's laws or?
- Well that's the problem, right?
Is that like-
- I'm not an expert so I'd love to know.
- And I think that's why at least
the majority of anime
Youtubers who have been caught
using anime footage in their videos
have managed to get away with it,
because in Japan we
don't have fair use laws,
but in America where YouTube is hosting,
we do our fair use laws.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- So it just never happens.
The Japanese look at that
and were like, "Oh shit.
Well I guess we're gonna back away now."
- Just put in the work that time either
to try and figure out if they can do it.
- It is an unfair system because,
it really just fucks over
any of the small creators.
- Oh yeah.
- You know what I mean?
And I feel like if you're a small creator,
the best strategy you can go for
is befriend a bigger creator.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Because if you're ever in any trouble,
then you're gonna rely on
them to make noise for you
because you can't do it for yourself.
And I can't really think of a better way
to go about it aside from that.
- Except just fucking giving up, clearly.
It's like literally no other
way of going around that.
Yeah, right?
- Yeah, it sucks.
- Yeah, it's kind of unfortunate
'cause even creatives our sizes,
it's still difficult to get things fixed.
I think the only creators I
can think of that would be able
to get shit done is
probably like Mr.Beast,
'cause he's obviously...
- The Youtuber poster boy?
- If YouTube's really friendly with you,
they'll help you out.
- Yeah.
- They'll figure out a
way to make it go away.
- Yeah, but it's like one out
of how many million channels?
- That's the thing right?
There's maybe like a hundred, I bet...
No more than a hundred of those people
who can have that kind of power.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause even we're big creators, I guess-
- We're big creators in the anime field,
but in the overall
fucking scheme of things,
we're just a fucking pebble.
- We're still decently sized though.
- Yeah but there's, I
saw this I think in 2020,
like beginning of 2020,
like rough estimate,
there's I think over 10,000 channels now
with over a million subs.
- Wow!
- So we're definitely expanding more.
- But you'd still think
that the ad revenue
that you're maybe bringing in,
is more than a Google employee,
so it might be worth having someone...
- Right, but how many
Google employees are there?
- True, true.
(Joey laughing)
Yeah, I guess that's tough.
- At the end of the day,
yes, we may be big in our separate fields
and maybe compared to
other smaller creators,
or people who don't do stuff,
but in a bigger sense,
the ceiling is very, very high.
- It should be nice,
'cause you know, there's
like 45% of your ad revenue,
it'd be nice to know that
they give a fuck about it.
Not just host the videos.
- Yeah.
- I mean they're big enough
where they don't care about,
they don't care about.
- Yeah, they don't really.
- 1 million creators,
1 million subscribers,
that's like nothing.
- True.
Yeah, I guess they didn't
really care about the credits
that can actually affect their reputation,
which are obviously the super big ones.
- 0.001%, right?
- Yeah.
- Because I mean, I get it
when you see on Twitter,
they'll be a dude with like 20 subs,
you're like man, "YouTube's so
unfair that the small guys."
And it's like, "I mean,
come on you have 20 subs."
(Garnt laughing)
I mean, you don't really
have much to lose.
I know you shouldn't be
discriminating against sizes,
but also I think there
should be a prioritize
on people who are living off it
and they've use the system throughout.
- I mean, I feel sorry for
YouTube at the same time as well,
because I'm like-
- You can't win.
- I'm thinking about this
from their perspective
and like, how do you solve every problem
that you have on YouTube?
Because YouTube right
now is too fucking large,
there's too much content
to be able to know what
everything, everyone is doing
and everything being uploaded.
It feels like it's just an
impossible puzzle to solve.
You jiggle around one thing and
then another piece pops out,
you know what I mean?
That's what it feels like, where,
I feel like they are doing
the best that they can.
And I feel like as creators,
we all are very grateful to YouTube,
but the sucky thing is that,
if we have a problem with YouTube,
we have to make them look
like the fucking devil.
You what I mean.
- Yeah, we do.
- Whereas my personal opinion is that,
I know YouTube's doing the best they can,
I know there's some massive problems
that happen where some
people getting banned
or some people getting
demonetized by accidents
and everything, and it can
affect livelihood by...
I look at this also
from the perspective of,
hey, this platform is
just fucking massive.
It's gonna be impossible to
solve every problem with a bot,
but that's what they need to do.
They need to have a bot,
because you can't have actual
humans looking over everything
that's being uploaded.
- Yeah because, hasn't YouTube in terms of
stuff that Google owns,
hasn't YouTube been in the red
for the past four years or something?
- Yeah.
- YouTube's constantly losing money.
- I mean, it's not the
value of making money,
it's the amount of information
that YouTube brings,
Google is priceless.
- Oh yeah.
It's like what, 50 hours of
content uploaded every minute
or second I think.
- It's way more than that.
(Garnt laughing)
- I think it's more than that.
- Way more than that.
It's insane.
- It's insane, yeah.
But no, it's scary.
But I guess that comes
with the price of it being
just a brand new type
of entertainment, right?
I'm sure radio and TV had
probably the exact same problems
when it first started to rise.
And it's only after decades
and decades of trial and error
that they've kind of smoothed it out.
- I mean, what I find funny is that
when YouTube first started
to get super, super commercialized, right?
And people will start
having all these problems
with copyright and a lot
of people taking advantage
of the system.
People were like, whoa,
this is a fucking dying platform,
let's go over to Twitch everyone.
And then now the Twitch is starting
to burst into the mainstream,
we're now seeing like the same problems
affect Twitch creators now.
- [Joey And Connor] Yeah.
- And everyone's like, man,
Twitch is getting so hard now.
- Twitch is getting axed
even harder than YouTube.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But the new DMCA Law's
are bloody ridiculous on Twitch now.
- Yeah.
- And it was the one thing
that Twitch was like,
"Oh, thank God we don't
have to worry about
playing copyrighted stuff
on our Twitch anymore.
And then Twitch was like..."
And when Amazon kind
of stepped in was like,
"Yeah, about that..."
(Garnt laughing)
- I mean it's more like the music industry
has just been stuck in its ways
for like the past 30 years.
- Which is weird though because
websites like Newgrounds to this day,
you can use copyrighted music.
And they won't do anything about it.
- That's 'cause no one owns Newgrounds.
Newgrounds is still privately owned.
- Right, but the thing
is just like is like,
even when it was in its prime,
the music industry never stepped in
and tried to do something about it.
They were just like, "Well..."
- Because the money wasn't there.
Like when the live streaming,
they see all of these
billion dollar buy-ins-
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Like they are pretty
same but music industry
are like, "Hello..."
- yeah.
- Basically, I feel like
it's just the contents.
Everyone tries to find
this new platform where...
I mean we talked about the
golden age of the internet before
where things were less
regulated and everything,
but as soon as something
does get popular enough,
it's just an inevitability that companies
are just gonna wanna get in on it.
And it's going to be more regulated,
and you're gonna have content creators
are just gonna have less freedom.
It's the unfortunate truth of the internet
and it's the unfortunate truth of media.
- God, I hate capitalism.
(hosts laughing)
Down with capitalism.
- Should we get into some of
our favorite YouTube channels,
or the channels we like watching?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because I feel like we all
watch very different Youtubers
or I guess...
- Do we?
- I dunno.
I mean we established like before,
that like the amount of
YouTube the three of us watch
is probably quite different.
- So like what...
Here's my first question to you guys.
What do you guys look
for in a content creator?
If anything, if anything.
Because I'm the type of
guy, people are like,
whenever I get asked who
my favorite Youtubers are,
especially in conventions
and panels and everything,
everyone expects me to
say anime Youtubers.
- Yeah, my favorite attitude.
- Yeah, right.
(Garnt laughing)
- And because it's my job,
I try to watch the least amount
of anime content as I can
because I don't want to...
One, it's my job, I can't
view animate content
in the same way ever again.
And two, I don't want it
to affect my own content.
- Also, so many of them suck,
I'm just kidding.
(hosts laughing)
I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
I totally agree, like you know,
my YouTube viewing time is my off time.
- Exactly.
- I just maximize YouTube man.
Every single moment of my
life I'm watching YouTube.
- I don't do that.
- Do you watch other Youtubers though?
- A few.
- Like other Youtubers that
you don't know personally.
Like I obviously watch your guys' content,
like people I'm personally friends with,
but I very rarely watch other YouTube
who I don't personally know.
- There's some I like,
but I feel like they're
not quite there yet.
Like they're still figuring
it out their style.
- Because they're new, or?
- Yeah, because they're new.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah.
- But I find enjoyment in
watching the new channels
kind of figure out their own way
and seeing their growth.
- I mean some of my
favorite channels on YouTube
are the tiny ones where
they've only got update videos.
- I love those, I love those.
(Garnt laughing)
Where they have more update
videos than actual content.
- Yeah.
- I would name one or two,
but I'm also worried that-
- You don't wanna bully them.
- I'm also worried that
they'll get 10,000 new viewers
and they won't know how to handle it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But...
- But you know the ones
we're talking about.
They're out there, they're out there.
- I mean, obvious channels
that we all like and enjoy
just like Internet Historian.
Everyone fucking loves Internet Historian.
I mean like what else, what else?
- Come on to the podcast
Internet Historian.
- Yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- Nakey Jakey is one of my favorites.
- I remember Nakey,
cause I discovered him...
You know when you discover a creator
who's under a hundred thousand subs,
and you're like, "You're gonna blow up."
That was Nakey Jakey for me.
'Cause I discovered him before
he even did his fucking
green screen effects,
and he was just basically try a mix
between donkey and John Tron.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And he was just like,
he didn't show his face,
it was just pure voiceover.
But he was someone who I
discovered really early on,
and I could tell, I
could tell immediately-
- Personality was shining through.
- His personality was shining through
and he was gonna blow up eventually.
And then he did like the first...
The first video where I
thought he was gonna blow up,
was he did a video about video game dogs,
which is so different from
what other people were doing.
- Right.
- But it was just so unique.
And I was like, "That's it.
That's your niche, you've found it."
- I just love his flow of comedy.
There are some videos where it's like...
One of my favorite videos to this day
is the one where he talks
about water levels in gaming.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's such a short video,
it's like six minutes long.
But it's just constant, constant jokes,
jokes, jokes, jokes.
- Yeah.
- With no room for error, whatsoever.
- Exactly.
- And I just love videos
like that where it's like,
cut all the bullshit filler out,
just say the punchline and
then immediately move on.
That's the type of comedy I strive to do
in my thing as well.
- I feel like everyone
thinks of him as just the guy
who has a green screen
and sits on the ball,
but as someone who's been
following him for ages,
he can do any kind of content-
- oh yeah.
- And it'll still be fucking great.
- You do a lot of writing, right?
So, I assume you think his writing
is also pretty spot on as well.
- I think his writing
is fucking brilliant.
- I think it's brilliant.
- It is really hard and
even I'm still trying
to learn this too,
to try and balance analytical,
like your thoughts and
analytics to comedy.
And I've seen so many creators
and I feel like even
I might be one of them
who sometimes it's like, okay,
this part is analytical
and this part is comedy.
But to combine the two
together seamlessly,
is a fucking difficult thing to do.
And to make it look natural
as well is really hard.
- This episode is
sponsored by Express VPN.
- Wow, Express VPN baby!
(yells)
- Okay Garnt.
But I understand you're
happy because it's December,
it's the Christmas spirit time,
which I have plenty of?
- Is it the big D?
- The big, what?
Which means we can officially start
watching Christmas movies.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeh!
(hosts rejoice)
- Which you know that I love.
I love them, I love them.
But what if you go to Netflix, Jerry?
- Mhh!
- This horror situation,
and you discover that your
favorite Christmas movie
isn't available.
(dramatic music)
- Then I will cry and
scream until I get it.
- I guess I just can't get it.
- I guess I have to give
up on the Christmas spirit.
- I guess I'll just get
depression for Christmas.
- That's what would happen.
But get ready to have your mind blown.
You can use in bold Express VPN
to watch any Netflix library in the world.
(puking mimics)
- Are you telling me that Express VPN
are saving Christmas?
- They are saving Christmas.
And this weekend I used Express VPN
to stream a Christmas classic,
"Elf", on German Netflix.
- Now I know that's your
favorite Christmas movie
of all time.
- That is everyone's
favorite Christmas movie.
- Very fond of "Elf".
It was so simple.
I just opened the app,
hit one button to change my location,
refreshed Netflix, and
that's it, that's it.
- So easy.
- [Garnt] See, express
VPN lets you control
where you want the sites
to think you're located.
You can choose from almost 100 countries.
- [Connor] Oh my God Garnt!
- [Garnt] Just imagine how
many Netflix libraries that is.
- It's a hundred Christmases.
- That's a hundred libraries.
- That's at least, that's over five.
- Oh my gosh!
- And of course it's not just Netflix.
Express VPN works with
any streaming service.
Disney Plus, Hulu, BBC
iPlayer, you name it.
Name it, come on, name it, I'm waiting.
- Let's be honest, Joey can't name it.
But let's also be honest again,
there are hundreds of VPNs out there,
but the reason I use Express
VPN to watch movies and shows
is because it's ridiculously fast.
There's never any buffering gentlemen
and you can always stream in HD.
- Express VPN works on
all your devices too.
Including phones, tablet,
media consoles, smart TVs,
your fridge, I don't fucking know.
So you can use to watch
it on whatever you want
or on the go on the big screen.
- Big brain move when you use
Express VPN on your fridge.
(Garner laughing)
- The one day man, one day.
- They'll never know where that cheese is.
- On my Fitbit.
- Disclaimer, Express VPN
does not work on your fridge.
- If you visit the special link right now,
expressvpn.com/trashtastes,
you can get an extra three
months of Express VPN for free.
So support the show, watch what you want
and get your holiday fix at
expressvpn.com/trashtaste
- Woooh, Express Vpn.
(claps and cheers)
- Link's in the description.
Thank you to Express VPN
for sponsoring this video,
back to the show.
I think one thing I respect the most
out of Nakey Jakey's run in,
like Nakey Jakey is
definitely not the only one
who does this,
but I think it's the
type of content creator
that I especially like
and inspire to be myself,
is the people who can writes scripts.
They're clearly scripts,
but they write it and perform it in a way
that doesn't make it look like
they're reading off a script.
Like Nakey Jakey is obviously
a great example of that.
I think the whole reason
why JonTron as well,
blew up is because of that.
- Exactly.
- He's managed to like, as you said,
mix the whole analytical
side with the joke side,
just so seamlessly.
And if we're talking (indistinct) as well,
a Demo was a perfect
example of that, right?
- I mean Demo kind of
just started as a new wave
of anime YouTube content,
- Yeah.
- And his style still prevails today
in a lot of people's content.
- Right.
I mean, I certainly look
up to that guy's writing.
- I think every pretty
much every big anituber
does in some way shape or form.
- But weird, not even like 10% of the way
to being as funny as that.
(hosts laughing)
It's like, we're trying really hard,
but we can't quite get there.
- It's like how, cause you
can copy someone's style,
but you can never be that person.
- Right, right.
- 'Cause that's kinda like the hard thing
about being an independent content creator
is that you can be influenced by someone,
but if you're influenced
by them a bit too much
then everyone's gonna be like,
"Ah, you were trying to be X person."
- You're just a clone.
- Unlike if you're trying to be X person
then in the viewer's mind,
all they are going to see
is you trying to be X person,
you know what I mean.
- Right.
I mean, it was that problem
right of back in the day
whenever anyone tried
to do any G Let's play.
- Yeah.
- And it doesn't matter if
you were no is similar to him.
Everyone was like,
well this guy's just a
PewDiePie clone, isn't he?
He's just a marker clone.
(Garnt laughing)
and am just like, I got those comments.
Like where I first started
doing clothes party,
people were like, "Oh, this guy looks
and sounds like PewDiePie."
I'm like, "Okay, I get the sounds part,
how the fuck do I look like Felix?"
- How do you sound like
Felix, what the fuck?
- I don't know, Apparently I sound...
I mean, I can do Felix impressions,
but it's not like I was
trying to do them actively.
Because surprise, Felix
wasn't the only Let's Player
that was around back
then and who I watched.
- Speaking of, oh go on.
- Oh no, you.
- Oh, speaking about Nakey Jakey,
have you guys watched Scott The Woz?
Have you seen him?
- I've seen a few of his videos.
- I've seen a few of his
videos, but I'm not subscribed.
- I fucking love Scott, I love you Scott.
Because he's the opposite of Nakey Jakey.
Almost where Nakey Jakey tries on purpose
to not feel like a script,
where Scott feels so incredibly scripted,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
that it makes it almost funnier.
I don't know, he's just
so extremely consistent,
and he uploads sometimes like twice a week
and it's always such fucking good quality.
- Right , right , right.
- But they're so good.
I don't know, I feel like a...
'Cause I was at one point as well,
Jon trying to not upload it for so long
that they turned Jon Tron
sub-reddit into Scott The Woz.
- Are you serious?
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause he didn't upload for so long.
Because everyone would
say that Scott The Woz
was like Jon Tron but more consistent.
- [Garnt And Joey] Right.
- But it's still very
different styles of humor.
And I remember as well,
he's like so anal about
keeping the same level of consistency
that he re-uploaded the whole video once
because he accidentally
didn't sensor a swear word
in one of his outfits.
(Garnt laughing)
- God damn, and that is commitment.
- He just seems like a such a chill dude
but also Hella awkward
cause there's clips of him
in conventions that he
looks so awkward in like...
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's like the kind of
energy that I'm like, "Man,
that's so honest."
He can just tell you that
he loves what he's doing.
- That's the type of genuine Youtuber.
- Have you watched any of his videos?
- I feel like, I've definitely seen
at least a couple of his videos
come up on recommended, but...
- I definitely have.
- It might not be for everyone,
but I think definitely you can
always watch it and enjoy it,
but you might not go away being like,
"I fucking love this guy."
But you'll definitely enjoy
it, a hundred percent.
He's really good.
- He's definitely on my list of people.
Every time he's on my
recommended, I'm just like,
"Yeah, I'll give you a go."
- It also makes me wonder
how specific of a subject
about gaming can you talk about?
Like he did memory cards the other day.
(Joey laughing )
He did a whole 30 minute
video on memory cards.
- [Joey] Right, right ,
right. And I was like,
I don't even know what he talked about.
I can't remember, but I enjoyed it.
But I just remember thinking this video
is totally pointless.
- There's another
channel that's like that,
which I think you showed me
this Connor, but, "Ahoy"?
- I was literally about like,
when Connor mentioned
that I was like, "Ahoy".
- I was like, there's another channel
that covers super niche
and specific titles.
- I for the longest time
thought it was some like
film studio that hired
the sexiest narrator ever.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- But I think it's
legit, the narrator guys-
- No, I think it's just one dude, yeah.
- So to explain to Ahoy,
he does video game documentaries
on really, really niche like subjects.
I think one of my favorite ones was,
he went through the entire history
of exploding barrels
in like video games.
- That was such a good video.
- And it's one of those subjects
where you never thought about it
until someone brought it up.
Like why is it that when you
see a barrel in a video game,
you just expect it to explode.
- Yeah.
(Connor laughing)
It's just something that
you've just been conditioned
to know, but then you think about it
and you're like yeah,
"What is the history behind that?"
- He's also like... I'm
looking at his channel now,
he's also the antithesis of click-bait.
(Garnt laughing) like it goes,
do you know what his video
on explosive barrels is called?
- Just barrels, right?
- Explosive Barrels.
(Garnt laughing) With a period at the end.
- I also genuinely don't think,
and there's only maybe one
or two people I can think
that have the same level of
production quality as him.
- [Joey] Oh!
- Yeah.
- The production quality of
this man's videos are insane.
- We've mentioned before,
but like, LEMMiNO.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's kinda like the insane
kind of production qualities
where you're like, "This guy
uploads one every three months
and I know why he uploads
one every three months."
- It's legit like box levels of it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's fucking amazing.
- He just did a video on what was like,
what was the first video game ever.
That's a very good video.
- My favorite one as well is like,
where does the history of chickens.
Like healing here come from.
(Garnt laughing)
And well, yeah, it's just great.
It's really weird like,
there are just some Youtubers I feel
that can just take these
extremely niche topics
and just somehow able
to turn it into a video
that you'd never thought you needed,
but then the moment you watch it,
you're like, "All right, I
kind of need this video."
- As I was going through my list,
I did realize what really appealed to me.
And it was like more so the human aspect-
- Yeah.
- Do you know, Noclip by any chance?
- No.
- They do video game documentaries
that are really, really well produced
about game development.
And it's really reached insane
production, great stuff.
But half the time I end
up just not really caring
because I feel like there's
no human aspect to it
or a personality
attracting me in the video.
- Yeah, right.
- It just feels like a documentary,
which is great and it's amazing,
don't get me wrong,
but it's not like Ahoy,
where it feels so passionate
from one person and so
many of the channels
that were mentioned today.
- Yeah, I mean, we've
talked about this before
about how to be successful on YouTube.
And I feel like having
that human connection
and having a personality,
even if you are doing a
sort of documentary thing,
inserting your own passion
and your own personality
into it as much as possible,
is the real selling point
of why people will want
to come back to you.
And I feel like that's why,
(clear throat)
like I remember when YouTube went through
this whole video essay boom-
- Oh yeah.
- And now I think it's last
starting to die down, you know.
- Especially on anitube as well.
- I remember when Every Frame a Painting
came along and started
doing video essays...
- Rest in piece,
but that was one of the best
fucking channels I swear.
Oh my God!
(Garnt laughing)
- And Nerdwriter and
everything came along,
and we have this video essay boom.
And now people, they
don't care so much about
the analytical side of things,
they care more about the
personality behind it.
- All right.
- You know what I mean.
- They care about the person
telling the narrative, right?
- 'Cause why should I listen
to some random person's college thesis
where there are actual
experts on the platform now.
Which brings me to my next creator,
which is a video essay channel.
Because they did a video essay on,
was it Shazam, Kazam, what
was that superhero movie?
- Oh Shazam.
- Shazam
Yeah they were doing a
video essay on Shazam.
He's called Ponysmasher.
- I've never heard of this channel.
- And he was doing a video essay on Shazam
by breaking down how hard it is to...
The little problems that need to be solved
when making a movie, right?
And I was just like, "Oh, it's
just another video essay."
And then he starts using
first person perspective.
Like, "So, what I had to
do was I had to do this,
I had to do that on this movie."
And I was like, "Wait a minute,
this is the director of Shazam
making a video essay on his own movie."
- Waw!
- And I'm just like, "What the fuck!"
- That's cool.
- Yeah, it was the director of Shazam
making a video essay on his own platform.
And I remember how he ends the video
is he says, yeah.
There was a point where I was just
super obsessed with YouTube video essays,
and then I started making movies
and now he views video
essays completely different.
'Cause he admitted himself,
as someone who has made movies,
he doesn't know whether, you know,
you can break down the movie's themes
and all the back end of
something with the movie.
But he was like, "Yeah,
sometimes it's just like
a complete accident."
You know what I mean?
- It's just a happy
little accident, you know?
- Yeah, sometimes he's just like,
"Yeah, did I mean to,
was there any meaning behind
making this curtain blue
or something like that."
And sometimes it's just,
is just the only curtain
that was fucking available.
- I just liked the color that's all.
- Yeah, you know.
- That's so cool.
- And hearing it from him,
after I saw that video,
I was just like, yeah,
he's kind of got a point.
When you've got actual fucking directors
making video essays on your own movie,
how can other people kind of compete
with that at that point?
- That's the point I want to get to,
where eventually if I
ever make my own anime
or my own Manga,
and I just make a video
essay on my own show.
(hosts laughing)
That'd be the ultimate flex.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- So I know exactly why they
decided to use these things,
because I fucking made them, that's why.
(hosts laughing)
- Ambitious goal Joey, ambitious goals.
- The most primary sources
that you could ever get.
- Also like, going the
complete opposite of that,
which is experts in the field.
My new worst fucking pet peeve on YouTube
is seeing videos of...
I had mentioned this
to you guys in private,
but there's this new thing on YouTube
where things that shouldn't
be a qualification
that are a qualification,
(hosts laughing)
like reacts to something, I've noticed.
And these things will not
stop leaving my recommended.
It's like Japanese person
reacts to every course abroad video.
And I'm like, "I don't care."
That is not impressive that
a Japanese person watches.
- The recent one I saw that
would not leave my recommended
is Japanese person reacts
to Bill Wurtz's history of Japan.
(hosts laughing)
- I was like, I don't...
This should not be a qualification.
I get it, there's like...
What was the other ones?
Like doctor reacts doctors, that's fair.
- Because that's an actual
quantification, that's a job.
- You were just born in a country bro,
what do you mean?
Its not like you were
born in like Machu Picchu
talking about the ruins
or some shit, that's tiny.
- My favorite ones as well
is the music related ones.
So I was like, I remember
I saw one which was like,
"Jazz drummer reacts
to Tool live concert."
I'm like, "But Tool is a metal band."
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
it's like, you don't know
anything about metal.
Its like you playing...
Oh yeah, the other one is like,
"Church drummer reacts to whatever."
And I'm like, you play
at your local church.
It's not like, you're
not even a professional,
you just play at your local church.
- Can somebody please
make a YouTube channel
out there like, "High student
reacts to high school."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
'Cause I just want us to go full meme now,
like it's getting ridiculous.
I saw, there was a mathematician one,
and in the video it was like
"Mathematician reacts to",
and I click on the vide and it said guy,
it's just a college student showing Math,
and I'm like what?
- I actually wanted to make a parody
of that video series, which is like
"professional degenerate
reacts to Hentai."
(hosts laughing)
- You should totally do that.
- I gotta make it now.
- You gotta make that
before it gets taken.
(Garnt laughing)
- Some people saw the lawyer
things obviously with like,
"Hey, I'm a specialized Japanese person.
I can react to..."
Not bashing on any chance to do it,
I just think it's really
weird and not weird,
but like unnecessary.
- It's kind of like, okay,
there's this trend that
makes sense, right?
You have a professional qualified person
who has been doing this job for years,
like a lawyer or a doctor
and can actually provide insights.
And then as with everything,
as with every YouTube trend,
people like try to bend
it as much as possible
to be like, "Yeah, I'm kind of like...
I have a qualification in X kind of."
You know when you're in that job interview
and you try to buff up your fucking CV
with as much bullshit as
you can possibly imagine,
that's kind of what it
feels like, you know.
- So have you had any past jobs?
Well, I used to have to take out the trash
every week at my parents'
place. (hosts laughing)
That was kind of an obligation.
- Like I remember back in the bridge scene
where people were just like,
"Yeah, I do sound design."
(hosts laughing)
And I'm like, "Motherfucker,
I know what the you do."
- Talking into a bull
yeti Is not sound design.
Dude, if you're any
smaller Youtubers watching,
here's an idea for you,
react to anything, but just call yourself
"Aspiring entrepreneur reacts to".
(laughing)
You'll get clicks like that.
That's free real estate, it's for you.
Okay, but to be fair though,
we mentioned this earlier,
but the "Doctor Reacts to Cells At Work"-
- That one was good.
- That shit was fucking great.
- No, like when this trend started,
I was all for this.
- [Joey And Connor] Yeah.
- I don't often watch reaction videos,
but I watched all of those
because the dude was
A, charismatic as fuck.
I forgot the name, it was Doctor...
(indistinct)
- I've seen it, I've seen it.
- I think my favorite one
is that guy who breaks down accents
and reacts to accents.
- He so good, the WIRED guy.
- Yeah, the guy on WIRED, yeah.
Derek Singer, I think his name is.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- I love those videos so much
I basically ripped out your mind.
- Yeah, you tell me.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I mean, I was like,
"Oh man, this is fun,
I can explain this."
- Not gonna lie, when I
saw that on my sub feed,
I was like, "Fuck, that's a good idea."
- Yeah, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- I wish I did that.
- I mean I thought, "Why not, man?
I've been doing this for years."
- I was actually gonna
do something similar.
I was gonna name myself,
"Japanese expert."
(hosts laughing)
I was gonna react to foreigners in films
doing Japanese accents
or speaking in Japanese.
- Right, can you still do it.
- I might still do that,
but I don't know...
- Are you a qualified Japanese person?
- You weren't born and raised here Joey,
I mean I don't know...
(Garnt laughing)
- I have a certificate though.
- How many years experience
do you have being Japanese?
(hosts laughing)
- Only 26 years you know.
- The amount of videos I've seen that has
"Japanese person reacts to Filthy Frank"
is like way too many.
- Oh, yeah.
- There there's so many,
it's like this should not be necessary.
Like it's just a Japanese-
- Also it's like, who cares?
- And also you probably
won't get a really authentic
cause most of the time the
Japanese people that are doing it
are doing it in English.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So they're like, you know...
I mean, I'm not gonna lie,
but the foreigners that I've spoken to,
or the Japanese people that I've spoken to
that studied abroad, are very different
to the Japanese people who are Japanese.
- I love that half the videos as well
it's like "Japanese
reacts to Filthy Frank."
And it's just an American
born Japanese guy, right?
It's like, "You're an American dude.
You're not even Japanese."
- That's an interesting point actually.
I would actually like...
That's interesting content.
Say you take a video and actually sub it
and then show it to a
Japanese person subbed,
and see how he reacts to it.
That would be interesting I think.
- Yeah, that would be interesting,
but the problem is no one
can be fucked to do that.
(Garnt laughing)
It's just too much effort.
- What other Youtubers do
you guys enjoy watching?
- Well I have a Youtuber
who is up and coming.
I found him fucking,
like maybe when he had less than 10K subs.
But he's this guy called Johnstone.
- Okay.
- And he's a Pokemon Youtuber.
- But unlike every other
Pokemon Youtuber out there,
he kind of takes Pokemon challenges
and kind of goes way overboard.
- Is this the guy who, this
guy beat the whole game
with a ditto or something?
- No, that's Pikasprey.
- Okay.
- That's another guy who I also follow.
So Johnstone is this guy who does
these absurd Pokemon challenges
and just condenses them into one video.
So like SmallAnt is a guy
who also does similar things.
He's a massive Twitch streamer.
But Johnstone kind of like,
he does these ridiculous challenges.
Like, can I beat the
entirety of Pokemon fire red
with just one Raj and shit like that.
And he not only puts his
own personality into it,
but kind of breaks down
how to do it as well.
So if people want to do it, then they can.
And I think it's only recently that,
you know, we were talking about
people who make content
which is very informational,
but then try and put their
own personality to it.
I feel like he's a guy who's like,
just starting to learn how to do that
and just kind of growing off of it.
And it's been really
cool to watch him grow.
- There's a few channels like that,
'cause I watch, is it Gamechamp3000?
I think I have it written down here.
He does the beading like X game
without collecting a coin or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And like, I don't know
why he would do that,
'cause it sounds like pain.
- SmallAnt does that too,
I recently watched him do.
It's like, "Can I beat Pokemon
fire red with only Shinies?"
(Garnt laughing)
So what he would do is like he would...
And he would do this all live on Twitch
and then just make a video on YouTube.
So every time the starters would come up
and if none of them are shiny,
he'd just reset the game.
And he'd keep going until
the startle was shiny.
- That's like speed runners kind of,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Dedication.
- Or another one was like,
"Can I beat all of Pokemon
Emerald without taking damage?"
- Oh my God!
- And every time he took
damage he had to reset.
- I think I saw that,
I think I've seen that one.
That one sounds familiar.
- It went quite viral I think.
- I think I've seen a few videos like that
where it's like no damage
dark souls (indistinct).
- [Joey And Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, there is always
a fucking trip to watch.
- I mean, I love watching
those kinds of content
'cause I think I've just
gotten so into speed running
and like just people who
are just way too good
at games for their own good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, there's a fair amount
of speed running dedicated channels.
Just thinking of it, none
of them are quite nearly
the level of obviously, Summoning Salt,
which everyone loves.
- Summoning Salts.
- I feel like it's Summoning Salt,
then kind of everyone else.
- Not to be rude to everyone else,
but he's just definitely doing something
that's clearly appealing to everyone.
- I feel like what he does so well
is that he just knows kind of
like how to present a story.
'Cause it's like, okay...
He's one of the few
channels where I'm like,
I don't really know
his personality, right?
But the stories that he picks
to present on his channel
are like a banger every time.
- Oh, yeah.
- 'Cause if you don't have a
personality in your channel,
then that puts pressure
to make the subject
you are presenting,
that has to carry your video, right?
And it's normally easier to have
a nice, interesting personality
that people want to come back to.
But if you're someone like Summoning Salt,
who for some reason knows how to present
the most compelling speed running stories
every fucking time, I'm just...
- It's like watching a movie.
- Yeah, exactly.
- His recent one with the
perfect Mario 64 record
is so good, it's really good.
- Yeah.
- It was so good.
- I also really love his...
Which one was it?
The Ninja Gaiden one, the cowboy dude,
I love that guy.
(Garnt giggles)
He's so nice and it made
for such a good story.
- It's so cool as well,
because I found so many cool speed runners
because of his videos, as well,
just because the way he kind of sells them
and also just kind of lays
out their entire journey,
is just like...
I don't know what it is because it's like,
truth be told, he's not
the most charismatic,
or interesting presenter,
but he just manages to write and present
and kind of tell a story in a way
that you just have to watch.
- 'Cause it's like,
there's always the hook.
It almost follows the
structure of a movie.
You know what I mean?
- [Joey] All right.
- There's the hook, there's the beginning,
the middle of the end.
And the end is always
like a really big climax
that you're like, "Wow,
this was worth sitting
through like 45 minutes
to an hour watching
just so I could have seen this climax
and get invested into this story."
- I'm glad I sat through
45 minutes to know that,
that cowboy dude got
a sub 10 in Ninja guy.
(hosts laughing)
I'm so glad these efforts
are gonna pay off, man.
It was so worth it, clap.
Everybody applause.
- You try to explain
this content to someone
who just knows nothing
about speed running,
and it's just like why'd
you care so much about-
- It's because he's tried his best man.
- It's one of those things
where it's like, just watch.
Like I think again,
this is why I love
documentaries and all that,
'cause I just love the human
aspect of stories and the...
I guess, almost human
life is more interesting
because weird shit happens
that you couldn't even predict.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think it's so interesting
and obviously like...
I also think that Summoning
Salt is really similar
to Frederick Knudsen,
which is like my favorite-
- Down the Rabbit Hole?
- Yeah down the Rabbit Hole,
which is like literally my
favorite channel on YouTube.
- I still haven't seen his new one.
- No, I haven't seen his new one either.
- I just think the sheer
amount of dedication
to the story and getting
all the facts there
is just insane.
And I think every time I get drunk,
I watch their "Wings Of Redemption".
- That's the problem with Knudsen though,
is that every time he does upload a video,
it's like a yay moment as
well as an oh shit moment.
Because it's a yay moment
because he uploads like three months.
But it's an oh shit
moment because it's like,
"Oh, okay, what day in my calendar is free
to watch this video?"
- You know there are some content creators
that you just watch immediately.
And there's some content creators
where you make mental note
and you're like, "They haven't loaded it."
And you're like, "Okay,
I gotta find time."
- Like "The Right Opinion"
is the exact same thing.
Every time he uploads, it's like, "oh,
it's another two hour
video about Right Opinion."
It's gonna be a banger,
but man, I'm not free for like three days.
(hosts laughing)
- I have so much respect
for "Right Opinion"
because normally I can't
stand commentary channels
most of the time-
- yeah, yeah.
- Because it's just the
biggest free for all.
It's like, I don't know why
some people are so fucking loud
and I don't know why some people
listen to the other people.
It's just a fucking-
- And it's almost always biased.
- Yeah it's so biased,
it's always a fucking mess.
But dude, if "Right Opinion"
makes a video about you,
I'm fucking listening.
- I mean, I was in one of his videos.
- (laughing) Yeah, exactly.
- Featuring Joey.
- Yeah I was in one of his videos.
Thanks for that, by the way.
- If I get destroyed by "Right Opinion",
I'm like, yeah, "Okay
I did something wrong,
my bad, my bad."
- But that's the thing, right?
It's like when people were telling me
that I was in like a
"Right Opinion" video,
in my head I was like, "Yay"
and shit at the same time.
(hosts laughing)
- It's like, you got a cameo,
you know what I mean?
- I got a cameo but it's like,
"Is that gonna be good, is my career over?
Oh my God!"
Luckily I was fine.
- 'Cause he has such a good skill
in breaking down the key
components about what,
you know, someone's personal mistakes.
- He just tells it how it is.
- Yeah, without...
He is obviously biased,
but every time he has
any kind of bias in it,
he says it up front.
And in the end, he lets the
viewer make their own opinion
rather than telling the viewer how...
You know, what opinion they should have.
Like he presents the facts,
he presents his biase
and then he doesn't say,
"Hey, you should fucking
hate this person."
He just says, you can make...
It's kinda like you make your own opinion.
You know what I mean.
- Right, right, right.
- I mean, obviously I watched
the fucking four hour video
in one go because I was dying that day.
- Nikocado Avocado.
- Disgusting.
- I got like halfway
through then I was like...
- It felt like it was
just repeating at times,
but that's because he
does repeat his real life
multiple times, his mistakes.
I think the only video that
I was kind of like meh on,
I think he made a video on
the animation community.
And I remember feeling like, "All right,
this is kind of like,
all right, kind of meh."
- Was that the done as a plan?
- No, no, no, that one
was good I liked that.
It was talking about
the animation community
and I think how they all rely
on each other for success.
And it was kind of like
warning that they shouldn't...
But I really didn't
feel like it was like...
I was like, "Okay, cool.
I mean, it doesn't really say anything."
But I mean, overall, yeah.
He's just amazing at
presenting an opinion.
Also, Frederick Knudsen by the way is...
Because we didn't explain what it was,
he does documentary on anything basically.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- Choose a documentary on anything-
- Any one personal event or anything.
- It was so well done that
it's just like, "Oh my God!"
Again, he has a video on
"Wings Of Redemption",
who I had no idea who that was,
but I watched the full two
hour like 30 minute thing,
it's amazing, it's so good.
- It's nuts how people can just
make a compelling
narrative about anything,
especially when something where it's like,
"I never knew about this
and never cared about it,
but I guess now that
I'm here, I'm invested."
- Yeah, because I feel like
I watched that content,
not only because it's entertaining,
but I also as this is my job.
- Oh I can appreciate the work so much.
- I appreciate because they
also break down as a Youtuber,
like how the best way to
present yourself online is in.
And the mistakes of what not to do.
- Write that down, write that down.
- Yeah, that's exactly the point.
Because they break it down
so well that you can...
If this is your job and
social media is your job,
then you can literally take
advice about what not to do
and the mistakes that
other people have made.
- It's like a self-help guide.
- It is, it really is, it really is.
- All right, don't do that, noted.
- Okay, wait, before we move on.
Okay here's a question for you guys.
Have you guys ever rehearsed
a kind of like an apology video?
- No, no, no.
(Joey laghing)
- You've never done?
Even though you've done nothing wrong,
even though you've done
nothing wrong, right?
Come on, you must have thought about it.
- Oh yeah in my head
I've thought about it,
but I haven't sat there in
front the mirror being like...
- Oh no, no, no, not actually rehearsing,
but like in my head.
- I've thought about it.
- I wake up every morning and I practice
the sigh before it begins, you know the...
(Joey inhales and exhales deeply)
This is a really hot video to make.
- In your head, you've thought about it
and you've gone okay.
- Well, there's a few ways to go about it.
There's the double down,
there's the do nothing,
there's the apologize
and admit wrongdoing.
And from what I've seen on YouTube,
it seems to be unfortunately
that people always want an apology,
but the people who apologized
and admit wrongdoing,
normally get the worst treatment.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I notice the people who doubled down
normally get away with it.
So other Youtubers double the fuck down,
just go with it.
(Garnt laughing)
- Every time, double down.
- Because I don't have anything in my past
that I expect I'm gonna need
to make an apology video,
but nobody fucking expects me
to need to make an apology video, right?
So as you see, as a Youtuber,
I see these trends happening.
I see like cancel culture happening,
and I'm just like,
"But what if I did need
to make an apology?"
You know what I mean.
(Joey and Connor laugh)
- Like V-Soul's music stopped playing.
(hosts laughing)
I dint need to apologize,
but what if I did?
Do you watch any other
documentary channels
similar to theirs, 'cause I have a few.
Actually, you know, on
the note of YouTube,
I think that EmpLemon makes
good ones about YouTube.
I don't know if I-
- I know his name.
I probably seen a few of this stuff.
- I feel like his presenting style,
I don't really gel with,
but I think the way that
he talks about YouTube,
I think it's really well done.
And he's clearly someone who is...
I guess I can see parallels between me
and the way that he
talks about the internet
and the way that like I was,
from like age 10, I was
glued to the internet.
He talks about how...
Realistically let's say,
I think he made a video
about YouTube likes.
- Right.
- So, on paper, if you see
90% likes to dislike ratio,
any mathematician would be like,
"That's great, that's great.
That's 9:1."
But a Youtuber sees that
and thinks, "oh fuck."
- Why isn't it 95?
- Exactly, exactly.
- So he basically did a whole video
explaining how the actual
YouTube like ratio system
is like 99% is good.
98% is you've probably off a little bit
of your audience.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- 95% is you've probably said
something a little bit bad.
And anything below 90
is like, you fucked up.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Which is true.
- It is definitely true.
- And he made a video as well
that was really well done.
I don't give a fuck about NASCAR.
He did a bit of a thing about NASCAR
that was really good.
He also made a video about
Hungrybox, the smash player.
- [Garnt And Joey] Oh, yeah, yeah.
- And that was a really
pretty good documentary.
- I do like I do like watching...
I'm not subscribed to any of them,
but I do like watching Smash compilations
every now and then.
- I mean the smash documentary
that came out years ago,
was amazing on YouTube.
- Oh, that was-
- Was that the four-hour
smash documentary?
- Yeah.
- That was the documentary
that got me into-
- Got me into smash.
- Not just got me into Smash,
but got me into YouTube
documentaries as well.
I dunno who made that,
but it was like this very famous
four-hour Smash documentary
that is like way out of date now
because it detailed, the very, very start
of the Smash community.
- Again, a human story.
- Yeah. It is.
- They build up the characters
of the story, and it did it.
Other channels if you guys
like Frederick Knutson,
I know you probably don't
know these channels.
There's "Anxiety War", I don't
know if you've heard of them.
Not Anxiety War, sorry, sorry, fuck.
There's the-
- I don't subscribe to a
lot of the documentaries.
'Cause again, they just take so much time.
- True, there's no Anxiety War, sorry.
I'll talk about him though
later, He's fucking strange.
Atrocity Guide?
She does videos similar
to Frederick Knudsen.
- I know that name.
- Her voice is so fucking
chilling and creepy
that even the ones that
aren't scary, feels scary.
(Joey laughing)
And it's like, (panting)
what's gonna happen?
What's gonna happen?
Very good, and then-
- I'm not subscribed to him, but J Aubrey?
- J Aubrey, yeah yeah.
- Every time his video
comes up to my recommended,
I'm just like, yeah this seems like a-
- Who's the guy who did that,
or who is doing the massive crochet-
- Okay, I was gonna get on with it.
- That's GenoSamuel2.1,
he lives in Japan by the way.
- Do you want to explain that?
Because Connor showed
us this the other day.
(Joey laughing)
- We'll talk about...
We'll be back to Joey
in some other channels.
So there's a channel called GinoSamuel2.1.
And like his whole channel is dedicated
to the history of Chris Chan.
You know who Chris Chan is, he's very-
- Infamous?
- Infamous online.
And the whole point of, if
you know what Kiwi Farms is,
it's a shit talking website.
That whole website was made
to document Chris Chan,
because there's so much information
about this one person online.
- He's probably the most
documented person in history.
That's the like, it's kind of like-
- I mean we watched what, like-
- Two episodes.
- We watched two episodes.
- We watched two out of how many episodes?
- I think there are nearly 50 of them now.
- How long were the episodes?
Like 40 minutes.
- At least 40 minutes each.
- So we watched an hour
and a half of this-
- Prologue.
- This prologue.
Not even the fucking prologue,
and the amount of information
they got about this guy's life
was just fucking mind blowing.
- From like age five.
- From age five.
This episode is sponsored by a Apari.
- shit, is that what
I'm wearing right now?
- Look at these clean fucking
clothes we're wearing.
- Look at this design man.
- Look at this drip.
- Is this artist owned anime
inspired quality clothing?
- [Garnt] I think it is.
- You bet your ass it is boy.
- Oh my God!
I'm not gonna lie fam,
this is pretty fucking...
I know I mean with a little
bit, but this is nice.
- Look how blinging you
look right now, man.
- I fucking love the bucket hat.
- I know.
(laughing)
- It's thanks to the
quality fabric by the way
and the original art.
Did you know that, though?
- It is anime inspired as well,
which is nice for the (indistinct)
- And Also, I'm not gonna lie,
I fuck with the color schemes.
- I fuck with the colors too,
it's really nice.
- I like the fun color code.
- Honestly, I saw this design
and if they weren't sponsoring me,
I would have bought it anyway.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, same.
- This is like so me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they gave us a cute little cute-
- This little key chain.
- So me and Joey are wearing...
Oh, Mayline is throwing
us an extra shirt to show.
A jumper, sorry.
- Yeah.
But this is from, me
and Connor are wearing-
- This is from the fall winter collection.
And trust me, these boys are thick.
I'm very hot right now.
- They'll keep you warm,
they'll definitely keep you warm.
- We are inside and I wanna take this off.
I'm too hot right now.
(Joey laughing)
So thank you, I actually love this shit.
And Garnt has some of the shirt
designs as he's mentioned.
He also has another one.
- Thank you Apari.
- God damn!
- Thank you Apari for
sending me more clothes.
I have more clothes to
wear on Trash Taste,
cause I am running out of my wardrobe now.
And this is the shit
I would wear normally.
- That design is fucking sexy.
- Honestly, that's some fucking sexy-
- I also got some facemasks
but they're at home
'cause they're dirty and
I've been using them.
- So put up an image, there they are.
- They are really fucking cute.
I had the most stylish facemask.
I do, I don't wanna clown all these.
But I did have the most stylish ones.
And this crisp bucket hat fellas.
- I do like the bucket hat.
- Because, no joke, when I go in the sun,
not right now obviously, but
when I get in the summer,
if I went out without a hat
I would just get a headache.
- But now you got it.
- Mayline said I was disgusting one time
'cause I sweat in her bucket hat,
that she borrowed me.
(hosts laughing)
- Apari releases new
collections every season.
So if you wanna stay up to date
with their latest clothing,
follow them on Instagram @apariart.
- [Garnt] Or sign up to their
mailing list at apari.com.
- Trust me fellas, you're not
gonna wanna miss these drops,
these are clean.
- Yeah if you want some slick weeb drip,
then Apari is the place to go.
So thank you Apari for
sponsoring this episode,
and back to the video.
- So his whole channel is dedicated
to discussing Chris Chan.
And you're probably thinking like,
there can't be that much on this dude.
They've made biopics
about some of the most interesting people
and they're only two hours long.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Where on that pod,
like it's something near 50, or 50.
And the reason why his
channel's called 2.1
is cause I've been watching
this since like episode five-
- Right.
- His channel got taken down at one point.
I think episode 15 or something
and he decided to quit talking about it.
I don't know what happened,
'cause he got out.
(Garnt laughing)
He came back, he came-
- He just when I thought I was out,
they pull me back in.
(Joey laughing)
- And he's back doing it now.
I don't know how far we are
into it but all the comments.
And actually Chris Chan
replies to every single video.
- Really?
- Tries to correct details.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Didn't even question about the fact that
he's making these videos, huh?
- Chris Chan seems to like it.
Sorry, I think it's she now,
sorry for the the naming.
But yeah, it's really interesting
and I hope that you keep
finishing the thing,
you get to the end.
I don't even wanna know how
much a mental toll that is.
- How far are we through
Chris Chan's life right now?
- I think maybe halfway, I'm not sure.
- And how many hours of content
do you think has been made?
- About 30 plus at the moment.
- Yeah, let's do the math.
If each episode is at least 30 minutes
and there's like 50, right?
- There was like 15 episodes
to just Chris Chan being trolled.
- I mean, when you showed
us that at your place,
we watched the first two episodes
and we hadn't even made it past age 10.
- With the majority of the videos
have been about trolling Chris Chan.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- It's a good chance
they might reply it here
but I mean, it's super interesting
and if you wanna...
It's so bad as well because Chris Chan
is autistic and constantly says it,
and constantly says
high functioning autism.
And in the documentary,
you kinda like in the start,
you really want to root for him
because he's clearly
just been unfortunate.
- He's had a rough life.
- And his parent as well,
they're super questionable.
And then the moment you're
about to root for him,
he's just like, "I don't like gays,
I think that blacks are less than people,
and it's like God fucking damnit.
(Garnt laughing)
- He had us in the first half.
- Yeah he literally has
us in the first half
and then it's like, God damnit, man.
(Connor grunts)
- You're so close.
- Because it's like the Tiger
King documentary, right?
They want you to root for Joe Exotic,
but they leave out all the
racist that Joe was saying.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah.
- I don't think I would
have rooted for him.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's just good storytelling, right?
- What I find fucking
terrifying about the first two
episodes of this
documentary that I watched-
- Sheer amount of information.
- Was just the sheer of a
sheer amount of information,
and the of a sheer amount
of intimate information
that I probably wouldn't
even know about my own life
at that age,
let alone someone else's life.
- So Chris Chan, the
one of the first things
that opened wide, like
the whole trolling thing
is that when it was all started,
and I'm sure the comments will correct me
if I'm wrong on these details,
'cause people are all
like Historians about him.
I think they call them Christorians?
- Christorians.
(hosts laughing)
- Is what they call themselves.
So...
- I love that.
- Internet Christorians.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- When they first started the
dramatica thread about him-
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- The first thing that Chris did was-
- Correct it?
- Correct it by overloading
it with personal information,
thinking that they would get bored.
But he just gave them everything.
- Yeah.
- And it was at that point-
- Zero privacy.
- I knew I was hooked.
(Garnt laughing)
Because I was fascinated by it.
- I couldn't believe that
he was the one who invented Sonichu.
- Yeah, he's the one who made Sonichu.
- 'Cause Sonichu was just...
If you don't know what Sonechu is,
there's probably a picture
of it on the screen,
this monstrocity.
The massive meme right on the internet.
And for the longest time I
saw that shit everywhere-
- Yeah.
- And I was just like,
where did this come from?
But now I know it's from the
brilliant mind of Chris Chan.
So thank you for that.
- Other good channels
that do documentaries,
there's a guy called Toad McKinley
and he did a two part
documentary on Chris Hanson
and that whole debacle.
It was really good, actually,
that was good.
- And how long are these documentaries?
'Cause I know you watched
more documentaries
than both of us combined.
- A lot of documentaries you can leave
on in the background I feel,
like watching the Chris Chan ones,
they're so long and often it's basically
playing a whole audio clip for 20 minutes.
You get the gist.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just a podcast about Chris Chan.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's just a podcast about Chris Chan
with someone else narrating his life.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- And obviously, I
watch J. Aubrey as well.
I think J. Aubrey is good
friends with Right Opinion.
- Yeah I can tell, they're
styles are similar,
but different enough that,
their content stands out for themselves.
But I kind of respect that
content in the same way
where they really know how to break down,
how public perception can warp an opinion
of a certain person.
- I think sometimes coming to channels,
I don't like being told
what my opinion should be.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I feel like
sometimes, some narrations,
like I think some video in J. Aubrey,
the way he narrates would be like,
all right, you should think this way.
I'm sure he doesn't intend to,
that's just the way I perceived it.
But I mean, it's still amazing videos.
- It's either one way or the other way.
Where if commentary channels either,
I know you're a fucking clown
and I know no one's gonna
fucking listen to you.
- Yeah.
- You know, someone like Kim Star.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- yeah, right.
- It's either one way or the other way.
And there's so many
commentary channels I see
that hit that middle ground,
and think that they are the
fucking Holy grail of opinions.
- [Joey And Connor] Yeah.
- Where it's just like, dude, it's just-
- And then you have
some commentary channels
that just kind of are commentary channels,
like technically speaking,
but just the way that they present shit
and the topic they choose,
just kind of go away from commentary.
Like perfect example, who
I fucking love watching
is Leon Lush.
- I love Leon Lush.
More humor focused, I think.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But technically he's a
commentary channel, right?
Like technically speaking,
but the way he presents it
and the topics he covers
is just like, just so..
It's like Cody Ko, with like the...
What's the series that he does,
where he cringes at shit?
I think it's just called "Cringe".
- I don't really watch Cody Ko,
or, what's the other guy?
Kurtis Conner is the other one?
That's like those three, right?
Yeah, 'cause I don't really watch them.
I watch a lot of...
I've really like Danny Gonzales,
I think he's really funny.
- Mmh!
- I think also the stuff
he does where he bought...
There's this video he made,
where he spent like
$15,000 on YouTube ads,
that was such a fucking video.
- I think I've seen that video.
- That's such a good video.
- I was like, I didn't know
who you're talking about,
but I remember that, I
remember watching that video.
- He has such a good personality.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- And Drew Gooden as well, obviously.
Have you heard of the
channel called "Anxiety War"?
- No.
- I mentioned it briefly.
He basically does how to catch a predator.
Like that's his thing.
- Right, right, right.
- But he's a psychopath.
(Garnt laughing)
I don't know how you can...
He spends all day talking to pedophiles.
I don't know how you can do that.
Like how do you do that?
That's weird, right?
- Yeah that is weird.
- But he goes and meets up
with them and film some.
And some of these dudes...
There's one dude he met up with
that was like eight foot or some shit.
This guy's built like a brick shit house.
And he turned up pretending to be a girl.
(Garnt laughing)
- What?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so he goes up...
He literally just does
how to catch a predator.
But instead of going there with
armed police and everything,
he goes alone with a camera.
And I'm like, you're insane.
- That's how he die.
- Does he have a crew or anything?
- No, no, it's just him. He
took it with a handheld camera.
- How many subscribers does he have?
- Oh God, Like over half a million.
- I think it's like
Chris Hanson hard mode.
(hosts laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
- One health.
- I think one time the
predator, one of the...
Sorry, one of the
predators tried to sue him.
One of them did.
I didn't know if it worked out,
but the guy's got a strange personality
as well when you're watching him.
I watch him just for fascination,
just to see how this guy does it.
But man, it's such a
weird presenting style
and he's constantly giggling to himself
while he's recording it.
It's really weird, but
it's an interesting watch.
I don't think it's like...
It's something unnerving
about watching it,
because the content
that he's talking about
and the way that he's
talking about, like...
He's talking about how
we told someone on Xbox,
but it's actually some dude
who trying to fuck a kid
and it's like, okay, waw!
- I'm kinda seeing a
pattern when all the content
you're recommending and it is very much,
you just like the human aspect,
a human kind of story behind it, right?
- There's a lot of channels that I like
that I just think the
guy is a fucking weirdo
and I don't really like the personality,
but I think they're just
so fascinating to watch.
- I reckon you'd love this channel then
that AKI recently recommended to me,
called "Soft White Underbelly".
- That sounds familiar.
- It's this guy who basically...
He's like this photographer guy,
but he basically goes around streets of LA
and stuff like that,
and he picks up homeless
people for whatever reason
and they bring him in to interview them,
and kind of like talk about their life
and why they're homeless
and how they got there and shit like that.
So there's ones where he's like,
he picks up a dude from the street
and asks what he's about.
And he ended up being homeless because
he raped his mom or something,
or did something like this insane crime.
And these people just
fucking break down on camera
and just talking about their life.
And it's really raw,
but it's so fucking interesting to watch,
just because you
otherwise would never hear
about these people's lives, right?
- Yeah.
- And there's like no bullshit.
There's no snarky commentator
or presenter being like,
so tell us your story
about why you're homeless.
It's literally just listening to a dude,
try and communicate with
this clearly broken person
for whatever reason,
and you just...
Some of these backstories,
I'm just like, holy shit!
How were you alive?
- It's so 50-50 for me with those,
especially when they're
getting homeless people.
'Cause I'm like, it's
such a fine line between,
in my eyes being genuine
or just taking advantage.
- Or this is kind of like reality TV,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- It's kinda like the, I don't know,
the backstory Olympics.
- You know what I mean?
- Like it's an x-factor audition.
- Where it's just like okay,
who has the worst, most tragic backstory?
Who do we want to cheer for, right?
- I'm already out, so I'm always like,
okay, some of them I
could definitely see...
God, there was a channel where
this guy interviews meth heads and stuff.
I can't remember the name of
it off the top of my head,
but that's a really good channel.
But he did like a really
raw, emotional issues...
- I feel like with the
way that you present it...
I've seen a bunch of his videos
and they all seem pretty fucking genuine.
- I mean, if you say so then I trust you.
- It's a gut feeling,
I've seen the fake ones before,
and this one definitely doesn't
seem like the fake ones.
- Just a lot of them
where it's like sad music,
royalty three and they've
picked up some crackhead.
(Garnt laughing)
- No, you know, if there's
fucking sad music in the back it,
it's probably fucking scripted.
It's like, you must feel sad
now because of the sad music.
It's also the sad music,
you know they've gone
from the YouTube library,
'cause you've heard it
a million times before
on like other channels.
- I see you're also using Kevin Mcloud.
(cast laughing)
- I was in a shopping mall the other day
and I was walking past this makeup section
and they were using that fucking ukulele.
(cast imitating ukulele sound)
Fucking ukulele YouTube stock music.
- Oh my God!
- That's my favorite piece of music.
Just because I can envision
every video that uses it.
It's like way too fucking white.
The white balance is totally off,
it's way too bright, way too sunny,
the background is way too clean,
and it always starts with, "Hey guys."
- Hey guys.
(laughing)
- "Today here's my outfit of the day."
- I look back to that period
and just think, well, why ukulele?
Why did every blogger at
one point have a ukulele?
- You can't be sad listening to a ukulele.
(Garnt laughing)
You can't play it like,
"Oh shit I'm about to cry."
The fucking ukulele like
(imitates ukulele music).
- But it's also the kind of like,
my family is dying around
me and I'm crying ukulele.
(hosts laughing)
Do you guys like "Report Of The Week"?
- I love "Report Of The Week".
- He is in a league of his
own in terms of content.
- I also think of him as
like a category of creator.
Like I can often compare courageous to him
in the sense of that's the
kind of charm that they have.
- Well, what other creators
do you think they are like?
- Buffcorell?
- I was about to say Buffcorell.
I wanted to shout out my boy, Buffcorell.
Okay, how do you describe
Buffcorell as a channel?
- It is just, you can never
leave one of his videos
not being happy.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- Just a guy literally Buffcorrell,
that's his name, he's buff.
He dances and sings.
His singing is horrible,
but in such an endearing and funny way
that you'd love it.
- But the boy can dance.
The boy can fucking dance.
And he's buff as fuck as well.
- Oh my God!
I love this man so much.
- The first time you
watch any of his videos,
everyone goes on the same trip
where like starts dancing,
and you're like, "Okay,
this boy can dance."
- Please pause this video
and go and watch one video then come back.
- And then he opens his mouth
and it's just like the
fucking worst singing
you've ever heard.
But then he does it with
such self-confidence
that you're like, "Damn man,
I can only respect that."
- You know what he is,
he's the epitome of this
is what I do in my room
when I'm alone.
(Garnt laughing)
But I decided to get a camera
and start recording myself.
- He's so happy dude.
You're just like, "Man,
I love it,I love it."
- It's so infectious.
My dream is to one day
have a fucking karaoke
sesh with Buffcorell.
- With Buffcorell.
- Please Buffcorell, come to Japan,
we'll have you on Trash Taste
and go to a karaoke sesh.
That is my fucking dream.
(hosts laughing)
That is on fucking my list
of things to do before I die.
- And I love as well
the little Easter eggs
he throws around.
Like the fact that he has a
picture of himself on his wall.
(Garnt laughing)
- I love that, I love that.
- The fact that the camera quality
is like the same fucking low
HD fucking five pixel camera.
- It is like, the one thing I love is that
he's not even pointing
the camera at himself.
He's pointing it at a mirror,
(hosts laughing)
that has a reflection of him.
- Epic dude, epic.
It's cinematography.
- That's the thing.
- It's channels like that.
Like him and like reported the week
where it's like, I don't
care if this is a joke
or if they're being a
hundred percent serious,
I'd still entertain.
I can't, I like, I would be impressed
if they were putting that one.
Because there's no way that,
that kind of genuine
happiness cannot like radiate.
- But it's the age old question, right?
Like with report of the week,
like, is that actually how he is
or easy just doing this
job until it catches on?
- I don't want to know.
- Yeah, right?
But like, that's like kind
of like half the fun of.
- I love the memes, I love
the memes of (indistinct).
- It's kind of just come
like this content creator
who I feel like they
just being themselves,
but part of that
personality is so infectious
that you cannot watch a video
and not come out happier.
And I mean, I could be
having the shittest day,
put on a Buffcorell video,
I'm like, okay, my day...
How can I be sad when he's not sad?
You see what I mean?
(hosts laughing) How could
I be having shitty day?
- When totally got these sick move, right?
- Exactly man.
- Dude, Buffcorell Twitter is the most
like blessed coast thing I've ever seen.
(hosts laughing)
Because like, I think
like three times a day
he posts a selfie of himself.
- Hell yeah.
- With like no captions.
With like different angles.
(hosts laughing)
It's the most like...
It's like a dude who just
loves himself so much,
but you can't hate him for it.
- I love that, I love that.
- It's like, "You have
so much self-confidence
and man, I respect."
- 'Cause it's just like,
I can't like quantify into words,
but like, what is the line between
like vanity and self-confidence.
And Buffcorell, he fucking
obliterates that line,
'cause he's so vain yet you
just feel happy for him.
There's no negative feelings-
- right.
- It's just, ah, I fucking love him man.
- There's this channel like
that's I don't know why,
it gives me reported the week vibes.
It might be an insult, I dunno, but...
It's called Project Farm, right?
All he does is just review
like engine oil and tool.
(Garnt laughing)
Like, and he'll like review
like different tapes.
- There is truly a channel for everything.
- Yeah.
- And he's just so...
Like there was a video and
he reviews like flex tape,
gorilla tape and could pass them all,
and like, "I don't give a
fuck about any of this",
but he's so passionate
about reviewing these things
and it's so genuine.
- What's that fucking channel
that reviews all of the locks.
- Oh, LockPickingLawyer.
- LockPickingLawyer, I love as well.
- He's like....
I feel like he's like low key,
one of the funniest
crazies in the platform.
- He is, I love it.
Indestructible lock in
the title, 22nd video.
It's like, "Oh, okay, all right.
He's just got to pick this."
- So LockPicingLawyer is a
lawyer and his whole channel.
He's like a lockpicking expert.
- Yeah.
- And he just, it's so funny
because he's built up so many in jokes.
'Cause he's insane at picking locks.
- Yeah.
- And like all his delivery is so dry.
(Joey laughing)
- He's got like the driest
delivery you can ever imagine.
But that's why every time he makes a joke,
it just hits every time.
(laughing)
- There was a video that
he made for April fools,
that was breaking into
my girlfriend backdoor.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- It was like, ex-girlfriend right.
- My girlfriend's back door.
- Oh, it was so funny, it was so funny.
- It's like, "She didn't
let me in the front door,
so I guess I have to go in
through the back door now."
(Garnt and Joey lauhing)
- And then there was like rust on the key
that he actually put things like,
I've got to get rid of the brown residues.
I was like hahahaha!
(Joey laughing)
- He's just gotta make sure the hole
is like well lubricated
so he can fit in the key and everything.
- [Joey] I love that shit dude.
- Like normally anyone else,
this would be like third grade humor,
but he's like the way he delivers it-
- It's the dry shoot for me,
fucking kills me.
- Such a good channel,
such a good channel.
Fuck, Who else is like-
- I think one of my favorite
video of his was like when...
I can't remember the exact video name,
but it was like some guy
who had sent him a lock
that's he tried to get picked
by like a professional
lock picker or something-
- And he said was it was impossible.
- Yeah, and he said he was impossible,
but I saw this one guy on YouTube do it,
and he just destroys this lock in seconds.
(hosts laughing)
- It's like, if you can do
it in less than two minutes,
I think the challenge was, and
he did it in like 10 seconds.
(Garnt laughing)
Like he just, he sees a lock
and it's already picked
when he picked it up.
Like, I don't know how this man does it.
- It's just hockey, man.
He's just like hockey, like on locks.
- And it's the best part is
there's no to these videos.
- There's no arrogance.
He just he's someone that
he doesn't need to flex.
You know what I mean?
- he Just really funny.
- He's just really good.
- Like there's minimal intro,
that all three minutes long,
but you get exactly what you want.
You normally end up like
laughing or giggling.
Like it's just such a video.
- I love this like non bullshit channels.
Like, I like Daily Dose
Of Internet as well,
just because it's just no bullshit.
Here's just like Read it top page.
With no filler, you know what I mean?
- From what I've seen on Twitter,
he's such a nice dude as well.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
(Connor laughing)
- So, okay, this is like super...
I guess it's kind of old,
but do you know "Imaqtpie".
- Yes.
- You know "Imqtpie".
He was an actually a league pro.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- He one of a streamer now, isn't it?
- He streamer now.
And like, I wanna talk
about him cause like,
I just think he's so funny
and he's like, he looks
like a homeless man,
that's like the joke.
- Yeah.
- And for like, I don't know why,
but for like six months in my life,
I could not get to sleep unless his videos
are playing in the background.
(Joey laughing)
He's got such a chill voice.
- He does have like that chill Jesus vibe,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- It sounds like he's permanently stoned.
- That's exactly what I thought.
He's just so chill.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- And yeah, no, I mean,
he hasn't been uploading
that much recently
cause I think he been
going through some stuff,
but I love your channel, man.
Keep it up, I love you, man.
(Garnt laughing)
Man, what are the
channels do you guys like?
- I mean, if we're talking
about league streamers
or league content creators-
- Gbay.
- There's one content creator I-
- All right, now I head out.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- There's one content I want to shout out,
which is Gbay99, which I follow.
I've been following his
channel for a long while.
And he used to make like very,
let's say like,you know-
- Youtubury videos.
- Youtubury leaked videos,
which is just like,
wrote a diamond where
he basically tries to
get his account to like high diamond
or high master or whatever.
But recently it's been...
You know when you see a
content creator evolve
and you feel like that
fat black proud father,
that's been me with Gbay.
(Connor and Joey)
Because recently he's been starting to do
these really in-depth
league documentary where-
- And even if you don't like league,
I still enjoy it cause
it's such a good story.
- Yeah. Because he basically breaks down
some of the most interesting stories
in terms of like the
league E-sports scene,
because he has two passions.
He's really passionate about sports
and he's really passionate
about league, right?
So what he does,
is he basically makes
these league documentaries
that are basically just
sports documentaries,
right.
- Yeah.
- And he goes through this
entire history or this narrative
and breaks down like it's
a a big sporting event.
You know what I mean?
- If you like Summoning
Salt you'll like him.
I think he's also sending
videos that he's been inspired.
The reason why I started
doing that content
was cause he Summoning Salt doing it-
- Right, right, right.
- And obviously, you know,
speed running is really specific.
- Yeah.
- And he thought, okay, well
I can make it about league.
- Okay.
- 'Cause it's been great because
I've seen his transition,
'cause he like, he used to make videos.
He's one of those people that
made video dailies, right?
And then he got to this
point where he was just like
completely burnt out,
and I then he became the
update video channel.
(hosts laughing)
There was a period in his career
where like every two
videos was an update video.
And he was like, "I'm working
on something big and I'm just,
there's a new direction in my channel."
And then he made like his
first big documentary,
and then he went from uploading every day
to uploading once every three months.
But it's like, what every one
of his videos is a banger now.
- Right.
- Because every one of his...
Every story he chooses to present
is like super interesting.
And as someone who didn't...
I was like, before I came out
as an anime fan or something,
I would like pretend
to be like a sports fan
and everything like that.
- Right, right.
- And so seeing him presents
league in the same way,
that's in the same depending way
that I see a lot of like
sports documentaries
and sports fans talk
about their own sports,
was like so refreshing,
'cause nobody did it for him.
And I thought it was just like so obvious
that someone could do this basically.
- Right, right.
- There's also a Exil who does like super,
that's more like league
stories about Champions.
- Still pretty good there.
- Yeah, I really enjoy Exil.
- But that's like hot
to recommend to people
who don't know league.
- Yeah.
- What are some gaming
creators that you like
apart from the Pokemon ones?
Okay, do you watch Angry Video Game nerd?
- Every now and then I do.
I like, cause I kind of
grew up watching AVGN
and I liked going back cause
like all of his old stuff
is on YouTube still.
- I know, I know, I love it.
- I love going back and watching
like the Spiderman episode.
Like that's still my favorite one.
- I think it's just nice in YouTube,
where the platform which
is constantly changing,
everything's changing.
- Yeah.
- It's just nice having an anchor,
like Angry Video Game Nerd.
- Yeah.
- It's just a constant, right?
Like, you know, whether
I enjoy the content,
it depends on the video, right?
But It's just nice having
a creator who's consistent,
no drama, just constantly
makes bangers like.
- Well, I think recently he
made an earthbound video,
which was fucking such a good video.
- I mean, every so often I go back
and see like the parallels
between what happened
to Angry Video Game Nerd
and what happened to
Nostalgia critic, right?
- It's kinda crazy, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- It's...
- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
- It's so gearing to see the evolution or-
- They were like the top two.
- They were the top two
fucking media critic reviewers,
and just seeing like Angry Video
Game Nerd being the anchor.
and whatever the fuck
happened to Nolstagia-
- Did you see his game show?
- No, I did it.
- Yeah, he did game show.
He funded it like via crowd funding.
He channel called them Ralphthemoviemaker,
I don't if you know who that is?
He does really good movie reviews,
really funny guy.
Really like Gordon Ramsey asked,
like just really brutal.
- Yeah.
- It's Pretty funny. Don't
agree with this takes always,
but yeah, pretty good, good channel.
But he did a video about the
Nostalgic Critics Game Show
and it is bad.
Like, it looks like a school project
and they spent like $50,000 on it.
- Right.
- And It's garbage, like it is bad.
- Have you like...
Remember that period in
like YouTube reviewers,
where they had to have like a
story behind random reviews.
Do you remember that period
where it was like channel awesome.
- Actually two hour views, remember that?
Unlike the first 30 minutes
it was like a garbage skit.
- Yeah.
- Whereas Amy Jean was
like, I can do that,
but condense it into like 15 minutes, max.
- I think it's because
it's also mega cheesy.
Whereas like, I think Nostalgia Critic is,
they're like the same thing, right?
- Yeah.
- The same quality, but almost,
I mean, that's kind of,
haven't insulted him,
but they're kind of the same thing
where they're like,
cheesy, obviously like-
- Very tongue in cheek.
- Very tongue and cheek-
- The playing in character as well.
- But obviously the two
wanted to be seen different.
- Nostalgia Critic wanna be
seen as like mega professional,
as Angry Video Game Nerd.
This happy being like, it's
tongue in cheek, it's camp.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And that's so endearing,
whereas seeing the Nostalgia
Critic try to be like,
you know, what's the movie he made?
It was like called The
Holy Grail or something,
that was like two hours
long and it was terrible.
- I swear like, Nostalgia Critic has done
so many side projects that
have just ended up being absolutely shit.
Like he made...
(Garnt laughing)
He made a fucking parody
album of Pink Floats The Wall.
(Connor and Grant shouting)
- Oh my God, I remember that.
- And I didn't, as someone who's like,
The Wall is like one of my
favorite fucking albums.
It's an album that's adored by everybody,
the movie as well it's amazing.
And then I listened to that album,
I got like two songs in and
I'm just like, "I can't."
But then I watched fucking Needle Drops-
- Yeah.
- As he absolutely destroying it,
and I'm like, "Yes,
this is why I love you, Anthony."
It was so fucking good.
- 'Cause it was just seeing a creator
just trying to do something
that was so unnecessary.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Like it's, like you said,
it was someone who obviously
wanted to be respected
and be seen as like someone
who did something great,
but it was just so like...
How can I do,
how can I word this?
If you-
- Self-indulgent.
- Yeah, it was very
self-indulgent, you know.
- And it was extra like cringy as well,
just like seeing that.
Like he was clearly
trying to be like funny
and edgy about it.
Being like, "I'm gonna
trash all over this album
that everybody loves."
I'm like, "Not everyone
likes this album dude,
like just chill out."
- Nolstagia Critic is a OG YouTube channel
that reviewed movies, by the way.
(Garnt laughing)
- Did we explain that?
- Did we mention that by the way?
- I'm sure that everyone who's
listening to this episode
give somewhat about YouTube.
- Never mind about him, watch
TheNeedledrop, he's great.
I fucking love him.
(indistinct)
- He was in New York times as
well recently, that was cool.
- Oh yeah, true, true.
I almost never agree with his opinions,
but hell that guy can talk.
- But that's the thing
I like about critics.
The good ones on YouTube is that like,
I don't have to agree with them,
but like damn, they're entertaining.
- Yeah, there Input is
still interesting, right?
- Yeah.
- I think like there's a lot
of movie channels like that.
Like YourMovieSucksDOTorg.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I like his channel a lot.
He's did a really good
video on like the Lion King
and Kimba comparisons.
It was like two hours fucking long.
- Yeah.
- It's a really good video.
I've really like a channel.
I mean, obviously don't
agree with all the opinions.
- There's also, probably
one of my favorite movie,
critic guys is a guy called SpookyRice.
- Oh, I showed you that right?
- Yeah, I think you and AKI
were like super into it.
- I showed AKI 'cause I wanted that like,
cause he reviewed like-
- All the horrible worst horror movies.
- They're are like worst horror,
it's disgusting movies.
- Yeah.
- And he manages to be
able to sit through it
enough times that he can write
a comprehensive review about it.
(Garnt laughing)
But you just, none of it comes in
because he shows it as
well when it happens.
- But imagine that YouTube, Ukulele music,
that kind of personality reviewing
like a horror thing like,
"Yeah, so then he ate the Shit"
and it's like, "What?" Why are
you saying it like it's a..."
- I didn't really like that
scene though. (hosts laughing)
- I fucking love this wall he's intro,
which is a, like, he like-
- Kokue or something?
- He's like cure the Kohan.
(hosts laughing)
And then he's like, has a logo
and then creepy go horns just
like shows up, I'm like...
There's no, there's nothing,
he just likes Kohan.
I guess I'm like, all
right, I respect that.
- What's your opinion
on like YouTube intros?
(Joey sighs)
'Cause I personally don't use it.
- I sometimes I think that I have to do it
to explain roughly what's
gonna, like the premise.
'Cause sometimes the title
doesn't really explain it
and I wanna explain it.
I mean, I just-
- I try to keep it to a minimum.
- Yeah, my intro is
like two, three seconds.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, I'm not like fucking AVGN
where I have a fucking
theme song attached to it.
- I don't mind if you have an intro,
if it likes serves a purpose,
but the ones where it
really, really me off,
I like tutorials.
- [Joey] Yeah.
(laughing)
- Oh my fucking God!
- I hate tutorial
channels or help channels
that have a into.
- It's not even a
tutorial or help channel,
fucking, I don't know why
every time I would wanna look
for a Sony Vegas tutorial,
there's always that fucking
(Connor mimics beat)
- Always fucking editing some Cod footage.
(Connor laughing) I don't know
why it's always Cod, right?
(Joey claps)
- And then on top of that,
they make a bullshit like
four, five minute intro
trying to put in their personality.
I don't care,
I just wanna know how to edit thing.
- Okay, so you picture it, right?
You're trying to install windows,
you get to the guy like,
"Yo, what's up fam.
We just hit 5,000 subs.
I think we can get 6,000 if
you really liked this show.
If you liked this video,
don't forget to comment, like, subscribe.
Because today we're gonna be reviewing
the window installer.
(Garnt laughing)
And when we break down
the windows installer..."
And it's like, "Oh my God!
Just tell me how to install windows."
And then it's like
literally like 10 seconds.
- If we hit 500 likes,
I'll do a windows eight installer.
- You know is redundant
when you Google search
on I'm like how to solve X problem.
And they pull up the
YouTube video that you need,
and literally skip a
minute and a half ahead
to be like, "Here, Google's like here.
Here's where I think
you'll enjoy starting."
You don't need this fucking-
- Even the Google system
is aware of how shit
and pointless the intro is.
(Garnt laughing)
- I've optimized it.
What I do is two monitors, right?
So the tutorial one tab, and
you go to text on the main tab.
So if you go through the text...
And if you can find it on the text
before it gets mentioned
in the video, you win.
- Yeah.
- No, it's so fucking shitty, right?
Because you have this like
minute and a half of intro.
So what you do, is you start
watching at times two speed,
then the tutorial itself,
they speed through the information so fast
that you're like, "Whoa,
Whoa, hold on a second there."
And you have to skip back
to be like, "Yo, yo. It-"
- It could be like a five minute video
and the tutorials is
like the last 30 seconds.
- Yeah, exactly right?
(hosts laughing)
- So egregious.
- Oh my God!
- What are some...
I have some other gaming
channels that I think-
- I got some gaming channels as well.
- I know that you watch
Darkk Mane as well.
I think dark Mane is really funny.
- Yeah.
- Really good comedic delivery like jokes,
he's literally the definition
of jokes that aren't funny,
but when you deliver them well,
they're just so fucking hilarious.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Right, yeah.
- He's so funny and I met him once,
I don't think he remembers
because he's very briefly,
but he was super, he was the
exact same as his videos.
- Yeah.
- He blew up at Lee content,
but he does general gaming stuff as well.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Just a really odd
guy, just really funny.
- Is he exactly like he is in his videos?
- When I met him he seemed like that.
- Okay.
- I, so he does-
- That's always endearing, isn't it?
- He does like, a very like,
what's that, dry delivery
of unfunny jokes,
sometimes funny jokes.
- Yeah.
- But either way, it's always funny.
- Right, right.
- And I met him in real life
and he was wearing like, he
was dressed up as Thanos.
(hosts laughing)
And he had like purple,
'cause he's purple-
- Right, right, right.
- He had like a glove on.
And I met him, and he for some reason,
he just like completely unrelated.
He was like, "I'm Thanos."
And I was like, "Oh, I see that."
- Sick.
- I was like, "Okay."
(hosts laughing)
and I was like, "All right."
'Cause I met his friend
RedRiotRoss as well,
He's really funny dude.
- Right.
- Really nice guy, makes great content.
I think also who would come?
- Yeah, one of my favorite
gaming content creators
is Core-A Gaming.
- About the fighting game stuff.
- Yeah, a funny game.
Like he does some of the
best analytical content
on YouTube, in my opinion.
Because his content is
all about fighting games,
but he breaks it down in
a way that's so general,
that anyone, that one makes you interested
in fighting games,
even though I have zero
interest in fighting games.
You know what I mean,
I have zero interest,
zero knowledge about finding games.
I come out of a Core-A Gaming video,
I'm like, "Yeah, you know-"
- You are the type of dude
who sees a how to tutorial
and like, how to stop fishing guns.
It's buying a rod on Amazon.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Like that is so gone, gone gets in.
You've watched the AlphaGo
documentary, right?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- And like the next week after I watched
this documentary about geos,
I want to buy a geoboard.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Let's play geo.
(hosts laughing)
- No, because I, like my one niche
is watching videos I
have zero interest in.
- I like that to.
- But watching like,
watching a content creator,
basically be able to break it down
in a way that makes me interested in it-
- That's true.
- That is my niche and interests.
And that is what I wanna
do with like anime,
to like with my own content.
- Yeah.
- And that's like the
content creator I respect.
So like with Core-A Gaming,
he like breaks down
fighting games on like,
I think like a social level.
He goes into like the psychology,
of why people act the way
they do in fighting games.
Like he unlike some...
I honestly, I think like
every video he's done
is the banger when it's
like an analysis video.
- [Joey] Okay.
- But he literally like
breaks down the psychology
of what goes into, like the
fighting game community,
why salt in the fighting game community
is like such a big thing. (Joey laughing)
And he also has like some
really interesting stories
in between all of this analysis.
- Right.
- And it's just like the complete package.
It's everything you want
in an analytical video,
but it's just fighting games.
But you can have zero
interest in fighting games
and you can appreciate what he does.
Because a lot of his
analysis can be applied
to pretty much just life in general.
- Right, right.
- Like he, there's a lot of like key ends.
A lot of his videos with
like a nice little message.
You know what I mean?
Which can be applied to
a lot of things in life.
- Like something you can take away.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I do need to watch more of his stuff
because I don't think I'm sad, but-
- Yeah, you gotta check them out.
- I think another sure the
gaming channels I like,
obviously the LilKirbs who
does the Mario speed runs.
- Yeah.
- He did the ship post of all time.
Because obviously Dunkey,
which we all like.
- Yeah.
- Is that the guy who
does the bows is big-
- Yes, so Dunkey did like the whole joke
in his Mario maker video.
If you guys don't know Dunkey,
I mean you should know Dunkey.
He's at the biggest gaming channel.
- Yeah.
- He did a video where he like
made his own level and got
the world record on it,
and was like bragging about it.
- Yeah.
- And then obviously Dunkey
makes any excuses in his videos
when he can't beat a Mario maker level.
Like, "Oh, you know, my
little brother was playing.
I was playing with a USB steering wheel."
- I was blind folded, yeah.
- So this YouTube Qaeda LilKirbs,
who also is just a God at Mario.
Like an absolute God,
who gets like the world
record on everything.
I think he's won like every
Nintendo speed run competition-
- Yeah.
- On Mario maker.
- Right.
- He did a video where he
obviously did Dunkey's course
blindfolded with a steering wheel.
- It's so fucking good.
Like I love that level of thing.
- It was such an amazing shit post,
but there's also like a
second layer of enjoyment
actually see him do.
- Like he's actually insane.
- He's actual fucking God at it.
- It's sheer posting
has gotten to the point
where you need to be like,
the sheer posting itself
is just your pure skill.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- It's insane, it's so good.
And also other gaming creators I like,
I don't know if you see Nitro Rad.
He does just like-
- I know the name.
- He does 40 minute like essays on gaming.
And it's just like,
it's not that warm feeling
of like watching YouTube in 2014.
- Right, right.
- Just being coze it up, you know.
Just watching someone
talking about video games.
Really like just be passionate.
- Yeah.
- I don't think...
I think there's nothing that's like,
"Oh my God, he's hilarious."
Or like, there's nothing that's like mega.
Like, "Wow, it should be unique."
Just all round, just a great package.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- Yeah.
- Just super such a nice guy
and just seems really into it
and really loves his gaming upstarts.
- That's always the best, isn't it?
one game on YouTube where I like a...
I kind of respect for a
different reason is a RelaxAlax.
- [Garnt And Connor] Mmmh!
- Just because like, I got into him
because he did this like
amazing analytical view
on persona five.
- [Garnt] Right.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And like, I respect
him because his editing
is fucking next level.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- And it's like,
it's so bittersweet watching a dude
who is like relatively not
that big on the YouTube sphere.
Who can just crank out like just
these incredibly well
edited videos, right?
I mean like, the whole reason why I,
you know, our editor Mudan,
the reason why I got into his stuff
is because that dude's
editing on his videos
is fucking next level, right?
And it's just like, I don't know.
I respect him as a Youtuber
and as someone who edits
like videos on One note and I'm just like,
if anything, I've gotten a lot
of like good editing ideas,
like creative ideas from his videos.
Being like, "Oh shit,
I never thought to do something like that.
But that's pretty cool."
- I felt bad for the dude
when he got in a bit of drama.
- Yeah, he did, didn't he?
- And I think he was like...
I mean, I don't know
what was right and wrong-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- But I think that he was
uploading a lot of videos
about it to his channel,
and I was like, "Dude,
I don't think you should
upload this many videos."
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think he uploaded like two videos
and the insisted for a week about it.
And I was like, "No, don't do this man."
- Just double down dude,
we've established this,
just double down.
(hosts laughing)
- I do wanna also mention that
if we did recommend Youtubers that turnout
to have done some up stuff.
Yeah, we don't know that,
we're just recommended
based on purely content.
- Yeah.
- We're separating the
creators from the creation
as much as possible.
- And also we don't
follow everything going on
and everything.
- Yeah.
I mean a lot of these dudes,
we just watch and like the content,
we don't keep up with what
they do in their personal life.
Whatever they do, that's on them.
But like, yeah, I'm sure,
I'm sure one of these crazy mentioned
is gonna be like, "They've
promoted someone."
- Yeah.
- They touch the kid or
something, I don't know.
- Exactly right.
- 'Cause obviously when you
PewDiePie recommended YouTube
as he got in shit for that?
- Yeah.
- All right.
- I mean, yeah, I wanna make that known
that any creatives that we recommend,
please hunt us for it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Also finally one,
I have one last gaming creator
that I want to recommend.
So I've been watching
this guy for like forever.
He's called like Caddicarus.
And he did like...
His whole thing way back was just a dude
who used to do just PS1 game reviews.
- Right.
- And it was kind of sad
because I felt like he'd
stagnated for a long time,
just doing PS1, PS2 games.
And it was kind of like, "Alright, nice."
He wasn't really growing much.
And then I'd say like last
year he really turned it around
and started doing some really good videos,
like insane amounts of effort.
- All right.
- Right.
- Like hour long videos about
like skateboarding games,
and it's really update.
In like, the amount of edits
in this dudes videos are insane.
- Yeah.
- and he's just broadening out a lot more
and it just making some
really good right now.
So if you like gaming content,
and also he's British,
and it feels sometimes like his jokes
are like British kids TV show.
- Yeah.
- And it's like, it's weird.
(Joey laughing)
Because like, you can see.
- But how so.
- Very stupid and very like...
I don't know, very crack Heady.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And it feels very childish at times-
- Right.
- But it's just, it's good,
and you know, if you're a 12 year old,
you can enjoy it.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And if you are 24 year old like I am,
you can still enjoy it.
And it's a bit silly, but it's good.
- Are we talking like
poopoopiipii levels of show.
- Sometimes, yeah, sometimes.
(Garnt laughing)
- I'd dig for that, I thought of that.
- It's just like, it's just nice.
Like you said earlier,
it's nice seeing a creator
just step it up-
- Yeah.
- yeah.
- And really like, I
just want to give credit
where credit's due and-
- It's especially nice
to see a creator step up
when they haven't made 70
videos about them leveling up.
It's like, just level up.
- 'Cause it's hard, right,
when you're creator,
when you're stagnating.
I've been there-
- Yeah.
- But it's really hard to just be like,
"You know what, fuck it."
I'm gonna put all this effort in,
I'm gonna take a risk.
It might not work.
- Just try something new.
- And like, most of the
time it doesn't work out,
but you have to keep it up.
You have to keep taking those risks
to get those awards.
- Yeah.
- And it's nice seeing...
'Cause I can relate
somebody who is stuck in
doing black butler for like two years.
I can really relate to getting out of it,
and I really wanna give
credit where credit it's due.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I think, I feel
like there is a space
for update videos,
but at the end of the day, the audience,
like for the most part,
don't really give a shit.
You know what I mean?
If you're gona drop something big,
then just drop something big.
- Yeah.
- If you're not,
then your like...
What you can convey in an update video
can be conveyed within your next project.
- Right.
- Unless it's gonna be like,
I'm gonna be away for like a month or two.
You know what I mean?
And at this point, that's just like
calling in sick for your boy.
You know what I mean?
(hosts laughing)
Like, "Right gang, I'm not
gonna be uploading for a month,
just calling in sick."
- Yeah.
- It's also the element
of surprise, right?
- Yeah.
- Like I've noticed that
like whenever I upload
something big or something
completely different,
with no pre-warning whatsoever,
it usually does better than if you do give
some kind of hints to it
because people aren't expecting it.
And therefore I think it gets
people talking about it more.
- Yeah.
- I think it's unfortunate
but at the end of the day,
YouTube, it doesn't
recognize the comments,
it doesn't recognize any of that.
It recognized clicks and watch time.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So if you can get that,
that's a bigger statement than being like,
"Hey guys, I'm gonna do some big."
- Yeah, exactly.
- One, one niche Youtuber
I wanna recommend
is Marshall McGee.
And he is basically a
professional sound designer
who breaks down sound designs
in like games and movies and anime.
- Oh, cool.
- And it's like, I feel like,
because he's only had
like 50,000 subscribers.
- Okay.
- But I feel like, it's
because sound design
is such a niche topic
that nobody thinks about,
but he breaks it down into like basically,
he hears like a sound from
like dark souls or something.
And he was like, "Okay,
here's how I would like make the sound."
And he like breaks down
this entire process
of like layering-
- Oh, it's really hard.
- Every sound he does.
And it just like, I feel like sound design
is one of those topics
that just doesn't get enough appreciation.
- Oh yeah, it's insane.
- And I feel like a channel
like Marshall McGee,
like breaking down, what
actually goes into this,
is like super interesting as well.
Just like how much effort
and like knowledge it takes
to be like, okay, this is what I think.
Like how would you take a
sound that doesn't exist
and like create it in your head,
and like actually make
the sound that you hear
in your head into an actual SFX.
- Yeah, I mean, it's like the
cartoon sounds like a Boeing.
Like what makes a Boeing sound?
Nothing makes a Boeing sound effect.
- Yeah.
- I remember seeing a video a while back.
I don't know if it's still up.
It's really all video of
this guy who broke down,
one sound, in one cartoon
and it was the fucking...
You know in Scooby-Doo,
you know when they go running.
Like when the...
- The running sound. (mimics)
- That sound, it was just a breaking down
how they made that sound
of why it's so iconic,
and just finding out what it was
and like how they made it in shit,
and like how they came up with that idea.
I was like, how do you even think of that?
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's just so...
It's something that you
just weren't expecting.
It's like, Oh, it's probably
just like a bunch of mallets.
It's like, Nope, completely wrong.
- Yeah.
- It's also strange, I mean like,
we think about getting punched.
When you punch, it doesn't
make it punch sound.
You just get punched.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
There was another video where I saw
like a Foley artist explaining like
how the Hollywood makes
the punching sounds.
- Yeah.
- And they break leak to break
bones and stuff like that.
- It's like break of saller rift
and make bones crack and shit like that.
It's like, shit's so interesting.
- Yeah.
- I definitely do watch a lot
of like music based Youtubers,
- Right?
- Yeah, I think some music ones are like,
there's a guy called Joe Jeremiah.
He doesn't upload much,
but he just like melodies of like games
and animated shows from piano.
It's really good.
- Okay.
- Just melodies, feel like maladies.
- We counting the SethEverman is like a-
- SethEverman-
- SethEverman is shit post channel.
- Yeah.
- That's the one thing I fucking love
about the music Youtuber
community, is that-
- There shit posting game
is on another fucking level.
- It's so shit posty
and yet they're all so fucking talented.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I know, right?
- Obviously like Davie504 as well.
- Yeah, Davie504 and like
SethEverman and other one,
and like, even like Jon
Sudano was another one.
Like the fat dude who like-
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- He did covers all this songs
by the replaceable
lyrics with SmashMallow.
(hosts laughing)
- Shittyflute as well.
- Oh yeah, Shittyflute.
- I dunno, like a lot of the music content
are like consumers,
mostly just shit posting.
- Oh, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- And music channels...
- There literally so
much you can do with it
and they've gotten really
creative with shit posting-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Ten Second Songs is another one-
- That really good as well.
- It's like super talented
dude, but at the end of the day,
you finish the video and you're like,
"I just watched the post."
(hosts laughing)
That was a post, but it was so good.
- But you guys to watch any like,
like horror YouTubers.
(whispers)
- Define horror Youtubers?
- Like just talk about horror.
- Like Corpse Husband and stuff like that.
- Not really.
- Corpse Husband isn't horror, is it?
Or it used to.
- I mean, he use to do like
creepy pasta stuff, right?
- I guess so.
- Yeah.
- Just could pasta like that.
- Like MrCreepyPasta and stuff like that.
- I don't want MrCreepyPasta.
I met him in real life, I think.
- Oh really, did you?
- Yeah.
- How was he?
- Thlod.
(hosts laughing)
- I hope he doesn't watch this.
I mean, I feel like it takes
a quirky personality, right?
- Yeah.
- He was nice but, you
know, out by my British.
I mean, 'cause most Americans aren't.
I'm tryna save this now.
(hosts laughing)
You were very pleasant,
but I guess you were a
little bit off, right?
(Garnt laughing)
- Wait, don't we have an entire clip that
which is like Americans
are different species.
- Oh yeah, we have.
- Yeah, yeah, we do.
- Check out that clip.
- There obviously ReingBot
who did the Mr. Anime videos.
- Oh, that one.
My unexpected cameo in that one.
- Yeah.
- Nexpo does some pretty
good ones as well.
I really like his video of
Redditors Dive Into Turmoil.
That's really good, have you seen that?
- No.
- That's about where the woman
who asked a subreddit help.
Man has to help subreddit
take custody of the kids.
And then the wife killed them both
when she saw the subreddit.
- Yaikes
- And it's just really, really-
- I know that story.
- I have showed you.
It's a really, like...
You just didn't expect
the video to go that way.
It's a really just chilling video.
And I highly recommend.
I mean I've spoiled it, I recommend it.
- We all know the best
horror channel is a Chills.
My boy Chills.
- Oh God!
(laughing)
- The greatest-
- No 10, burger King foot.
- Dude, I can't tell you how happy I was
that I was in one of his videos.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And he said my name,
I was like, I've made it as a YouTuber.
Like, it's peak.
- Have you seen the video
where he just talks.
He's such a genuine and nice guy as well.
- Like-
- Chills.
- Yeah, because like that's
just how he talks, right?
- Yeah, that's how he talks.
- Because everybody
thinks he's like purposely
trying to make this like annoying accent,
but like videos where he
just like talks off script.
That's just how he talks.
- You wanna give him a high five.
- Yeah.
- So nice bless him.
- Dude, Chills I fucking love you.
You're like, please come onto the podcast.
It would be the most
basic sounding podcast.
- Also a guy who popped
up not too long ago,
Barely Sociable.
He does really good videos.
He did a really good video
on the silk road as well.
- Oh, I might've seen that.
- What's a Silk road.
- It was the website that was famous
on the deep web for selling drugs.
- Oh, okay.
- And I thought it was some like
mastermind criminal organization,
but it turned out it was just some dudes,
like petty and fighting
about getting trolled.
- I feel like I've seen a
lot of these guys' content
on like my recommended.
And I've watched it.
It's because like,
it's not the type of content
I would subscribe to.
But if it's like, if it's
an interesting enough topic,
I'm willing to click on
anything on my recommended.
- What about educational channel voice.
What educational channels
do you guys watch?
- Oh!
- I mean Vsauce is the one that-
- I didn't really upload.
- They haven't bought in a while,
but is it even Vsauce source anymore?
Cause he like,
he's doing like minefield or mine. Yeah.
I haven't seen any other
channel called Dong.
Do you remember that?
And then YouTube forced him
to change it to like Ding,
because Dong was obviously-
- See was like penis, yeah.
- I can't believe that, that's awful.
- Are we counting like
engineering video educational?
- Yes, of course.
- Because I feel like engineering
has had like a resurgence
within this past few years.
Thanks to creators like
Michael Reeves, Willam Osman.
- Mark Rober.
- And Mark Rober.
- Like I wish they were around
when I was in fucking university.
- Yeah, right.
- Because I didn't know
engineering could be cool
until they started making content man.
(laughing)
- I think especially like
the posting ones like
Michael Reeves.
I mean I found Michael Reese
when he was doing like,
when he was branded as like the laser guy.
- Yeah.
- He made one video about
a laser pointing in his eye
and for like months, his
channel was like everything.
- He was the laser dude.
Yeah.
And it was so it's so cool
seeing and blow up and also just
making engineering. Cool.
Yeah. Like William Osman and Mark Robert.
- I think, I think the latest video,
the latest creator I discovered
was a stuff made here.
I love stuff, man.
He's just, he's just like
someone who is just, I don't,
I don't know what it is about
him that like stands out like
even more. Cause he's not,
he's not a poster one.
No, no.
He's, he's like a very
serious engineering one,
but he just makes these really
cool contraptions and some of
the stuff he makes takes so
much effort. It's insane.
- How high the bar? The bar,
like the bar for like good engineering.
The explosive bat. Yeah.
What the? Like, like
he made a baseball bat,
but it has like four shells
in it when you hit it.
It explodes and object
to thing that yeah. Yeah.
Basically he basically the
concept was he wanted to make a
baseball bat that anyone could
use to like get a home run.
Right, right, right.
I'd like to, to like, yeah.
Break the world record
for home run. And so he,
just puts shotgun shells
into this baseball bat and he
breaks down his entire
process about how to make this
feasible. And it's like the first,
the first problem he had
to overcome was like, he,
he made a baseball bat that worked,
but anyone who would use it
would break that arm if they
used it. Right.
And it's like his level or his
like knowledge and level of
engineering is just like
on a different scale.
Fantastic presentation
and great presentation.
There's actually a Japanese, YouTube.
I don't watch many Japanese. Yeah.
But because frankly they're all quite man,
but there's one Japanese Ichiba
who like blew up recently or
like quite recently
who's like kind of like,
he's like halfway between
engineering and just absolute
post.
Okay. And,
and he does these videos
where it's basically just him
having fun. It's the guy who
like a himself on like a call.
Yes. Yeah.
He, he does like, he basically is like,
he was the one who popularized the,
if you carve out a watermelon
and then you boil salt water
to a thousand degrees and
you pour it in the watermelon
explodes, I found that he did apparently,
but like the UN a recent
one that he did was like,
he was like, I love popcorn.
So I'm going to make a, I
think it was like a 50 meter,
long popcorn container and
just fill it up with popcorn.
And then he did that and it's
massive and it's all filled up
with popcorn,
but then he took it one step
further and he invited his
friends and he pranked them by
making this fake room in his
studio so that the popcorn would
fall in as if it would keep
into the house.
And it was insane. And
the videos are so short.
He just manages like condense
that it's like a five minute
kind of like, it sounds
like David doebrick right.
Just doing it. Same thing is he,
he just does the most insane.
Like there was another one
where he like, you know, he,
he wanted to replicate the,
the force of someone going into space,
but obviously you
couldn't afford a rocket.
So what he did was he created
this contraption where it
would explode underneath him
and it would just inject,
it flew like 50 meters into
the air and like almost broke
his neck and he's just
laughing the entire time.
I'm like this guy's a psycho,
but he's so fun to watch.
And Japanese cubes are like
insane, but that's the thing.
It's like, he's a Japanese teacher,
but like he can only speak
Japanese and all that,
but he just presents things.
It's so visual that you don't
have to understand what he's
saying to be such an entertaining video.
Like we're getting,
we're now getting to the point in YouTube,
where to stand out,
you need to like have genuine
qualifications and experience
behind the stuff you do,
because it's like some of these,
a lot of these creators that
we've mentioned can easily get
jobs.
- In the, in their field,
in their professional field.
I mean, decos, I think he's only like 18,
am I like a wizard engine?
- Jesus Christ. I mean, it
goes to show that right.
Cause like the quality of the
engineering is like so insane
at this point.
Then you have like the top
channels that doing it. Like,
Oh my God. Yeah.
Like I have an engineering
degree and I'm like baffled.
- Like apps three years.
I have a master's in engineering
and some of the stuff
they're coming up with this,
just like, man, this is,
this is this what I would have
done if I had stayed in my
engineering course.
- And he made the surgery robot.
Oh yeah.
what the?
I, I met him as well.
And he was like the
nicest dude ever. Right.
Like,
because we were at the anime
awards and he was leaving and
we didn't really get
a chance to talk much.
Now came over just to say bye to me. Like.
- It sounds like, wow, dude,
like people don't normally
do that. That's really fun.
I mean.
- And Lily Petri was super nice. Yeah.
Like what I've seen the offline
TV crew just seemed like
great. Yeah.
Trashy stuff like TV collab. When.
- When the world opens,
when the world opens up and
we can fly to places or that I
can fly to places who the knows.
- So many educational channels.
Like obviously like everyone
wants you to CPG gray. Yeah.
To watch Tom Scott.
- Yeah. Where's Tom Scott.
I subscribe to Tom Scott, but man,
his videos will not leave my room.
He says one of those channels
that I just know we've got,
like, I don't even need to
subscribe to your channel.
- I used to, I used to,
whenever I used to go to the
YouTube studio in London,
he's always there.
I just editing his videos
and I never said hi.
Cause I felt bad editing, but.
- He seems like a machine.
I respect,
I respect because I respect
his work ethic because he has
like a schedule. I don't
know how he's able to upload.
So consistently with like the,
the amount of videos he has.
- Corona and he's somehow
still going abroad.
- I like, he has like
really interesting ideas.
So consistently like his, his video where,
where it was about like this
video has X amount of views
that just fall back guy.
He's the one he made there.
Yeah. Yeah.
I knew, I knew his name was familiar.
Yeah.
- We don't have red shirts.
That guy.
- And what,
what impresses me the most
actually is how he's able to
present his information
with like zero cuts it.
Like without a script, just,
just in, just in one test.
How does he do that?
- You get like a Disani
video about like the Sony,
the water bottle. It's
like a five minute video.
Does it all in one tape, down the street.
And I'm like, what?
Like.
- How are you doing?
This is so professional.
So good. I'm reading off a script.
And even I need like
five takes to get one.
- I do love the memes
of like, Oh, I'm here.
Have you seen those memes? Right?
- Yeah. Breaking, breaking down.
The Tom Scott.
- Obviously this cook has got cook is
because everyone loves him. I mean.
- Well, we're going to notch.
Wasn't he? Like,
didn't he try to change his
name to like in a nutshell,
start in a nutshell. Yeah.
I like Veritasium as one
of these really good terms.
Amazing. Yeah.
- Real life.
- Yeah. Real life.
Like obviously smarter every day as well.
Do you guys watch, I've seen Mike Boyd,
the guy like loons things like
he'll like spend like a week
just learning something and you know,
he won't stop the video
until he does it. So like,
he'll learn how there's one
video where he learned to us
shattered glass with his voice.
I feel like I've seen that everywhere.
I feel like it's really good.
And he just learns like
completely useless.
- I know,
I know a boy in a band did kind
of a parody of that where he
learned to sing in 30 days. Oh yeah.
Yeah. That was cool.
Yeah. Which was really cool.
Yeah. Pretty good.
- Highly recommend it.
There's also like casually,
casually explained is also
kind of similar to like.
- I, I, so like is, is he
educational or is he meme?
Do you know? Do you know.
- Salmonella, salmonella?
He does like casually explained, but.
- Because, because here's the thing,
I think that's the part,
that's the thing like there's like,
there's like engineering and
what educational Youtubers are.
Then there's like casualty,
planes and tear zoo who are
just like, I mean the, the tape,
what they say is
technically correct. Right.
Is anyone actually watching
them to be like educated?
Really? Nah, probably not.
Have you watched Jewish Jay
foreman? I do not watch.
- He does videos mainly about London,
like history of London
and stuff. And like,
it's just so insane. How well
produced these videos are.
I also met him ages ago.
He doesn't remember because
he was like four years ago.
Yeah. And he's just
obsessed with London and,
but his videos are so well
done. And it's so funny.
And like, he'll,
he'll just do a shot where
he's just in the middle of the
street in London for like two seconds.
But he has to get a
camera man. He had to get,
they had to set it all up.
It's like, it's in the same.
Wow. And it's just all
to talk about London.
Most of the time I'd highly recommend it.
If you like just general
history about London.
- Fair enough. I mean recently,
like I've definitely found myself.
I used to not watch a lot of
the YouTube videos from like
the really like big
like corporate channels.
I didn't really like
the corporate channels.
I used to look at like Wyatt
and Fox channels and be like,
Oh, it's just like a.
- Like, I want you to channel
called chatter sometimes.
But I feel just so sad.
- Okay. That name sounds familiar.
- They always do the video.
Like why New York has big skylines?
Why electric calls on in America?
It's like such generic titles of like,
I don't know why Walmart
is big. And it's like,
every single video is so lifeless.
- Yeah. And like, it's informative.
I will say there's sad. There,
there is one kind of like,
I'd say cooperation kind of
video that I do enjoy. I'm not,
I don't know if this is
the name of the channel,
but the name of the series
is like big, great story.
They actually have like really
cool and interesting stories.
I think one of my favorite
videos of them was like, they,
they,
they were in Japan and there
was this like Japanese person
who sells painting made
in Microsoft Excel. What?
I haven't seen that.
I've never seen that one.
So there's this guy who,
there was this Japanese guy who just like,
he just wanted to express himself,
cost zero skills of Japan. Japan.
We do a lot of things in Japan,
but like he had zero skills
in like painting and like,
you know, art skills.
So he just side,
like making pictures in
Microsoft Excel and the actually
like he he's been doing it for
so long that they'd started
to become really good. Right.
And it was just like such a
like uplifting story to just be
like, it doesn't really matter
what your tools are now.
That is a big grid step. That
is the big story. Always.
- Super concise as well.
They're not too long.
And it's just.
- Great.
There's also another story
about this soup that is being
like made in Thailand or something.
It's like 50 years old.
It's like been boiling for
50 years. I don't remember.
I remember watching it and
it was just like, they,
they didn't want wash the place at all.
So the oil had been built up.
So there was a mountain
next to this massive pot.
Have you been there?
I have not been there.
You're going to go back down
when you go to Thailand,
if you ever like take us to Thailand,
which I'm sure will happen.
Eventually we really want to go.
I actually want to like
see if it's good or not.
If you guys want a channel
called a captain disillusion.
Yes.
3D, like.
- Blender.
- Breaks things down. So well.
And he like.
- He's too talented for
YouTube as well. I think.
- There were just some channels out there
that are just like,
like cartel digital is one
that was just way too talented
for YouTube.
- I feel bad. Cause he
doesn't upload often.
But you can tell that he like, I dunno,
maybe he just wants to
do a bit more. Yeah.
But I found them ages ago.
Cause he's been uploading
for like 10 years.
Like his first videos are in
like three 60 P Oh Jesus. So.
- Yeah.
I mean he came up with at the
same time as like Freddie w
and a rocket jump. I think,
I think they didn't blow up
until like two years ago. Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Cause I remember, I
remember he was like back,
back in the day, it was like
Freddie w and rocket jump,
taking over the YouTube scene
and then every other VX B
effects specialist was
like after him. Yeah.
And then, you know, they,
they kind of like did their
own thing and then that,
that like gave way to like
other people like corridor
digital. Yeah.
- Everything like that.
Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, there's also another channel.
I like the, you know, the Jonny
Harris, the guy left Volks,
the guy used to be the boarders on Fox.
Right.
Challenge. It's just the same thing.
Sound good. Quality.
I'd recommend it.
It's already been blowing
up a lot on YouTube.
So I'm sure you probably seen
the videos and you recommended
the video of like why'd you
Americans eat dessert for
breakfast. That blew up a ton.
- I think so. Yeah.
I might have seen that
one, one, like, as I said,
like once I never used to
watch Voxer or anything,
but like the earworm
series is so good. Like.
- It's essentially like
a one person who's.
- In charge of that.
It's like one woman at Vox who
just like does all these like
really in-depth analysis,
documentaries on like music
history and stuff like that.
It's do the editing. It's insane.
It's so good. This episode
is sponsored by book Walker.
- Cool guys announced their
year end ranking results for the
best-selling e-books.
- Yes. And until December 8th
you can get up to 50 coin.
- Back on series that
made it on off. No way.
So this is the top overall rankings.
- Best selling books on
bulk order. This year,
I'll go through the rankings
of the top for each element.
You can start with number three.
- Well,
number three is my next life
as a villainous old routes,
lead to doom. Lighten up.
- Yeah, no, I have not read this one.
- I have no read this one, but
I have read the second one,
which is a sentence of a bulk. Woah.
That's actually a really
cute Lionel that is game.
And it's really well
received. Like really good.
It's it kind of gives me like
spice of Wolf fives. Oh yeah.
That was really good.
- The first one I can
announce this one day.
No, don't worry.
I can announce this
one. If you like, it is,
you are my princess volume collections.
achievement. God.
Wow.
Best selling ebook frame that
frame that and put it on your
isolation. Seadog VA number
one, selling ebook of 2020.
You all my princess falling water. Okay.
To go with wow. Magical.
Where's my flowers Malin. You
know, I just want to thank.
- Everyone involved me.
- Shout is able to help me. I do.
Wow.
- There's some people
involved, dude is Epic.
I mean,
it's crazy to me that something
that I made could sell as
much as other like legitimate. Yeah.
The audio book version, right?
Yeah. I don't know.
She just, she's a scary man.
I, I, you know, when you,
when you make a story around a product,
I feel like people are more
likely to give it a shot,
you know? And I think
people could see my blood,
sweat and tears. It's
really awkward to hold.
I'll put it that for now. Yeah.
I don't know. Thank you.
Thank you bookwork.
- So moving on to the top
Mongo. Well, well, well,
well why did we start?
Why did we start with
the top overall Malin?
I feel like it should have
been the last category.
So the top manga setting
overall at number three is don't
toy with me. Miss negatory.
Oh yeah. That's a good Mongo.
I'm surprised that's number.
- I'm surprised. It's number three.
It is a good mungus. It's wholesome.
Tan go cute. Number two.
- The cultured individuals really
is interspecies reviewers at
number two. Am I surprised?
No. That just means there are
that many degenerates on book
Walker right now. I'm very proud.
I'm proud of you boys. I'm
proud of you, but overall.
- Of course we have to talk
about the number one top Mongo.
I don't want to talk about it.
- What is it called?
mine. Oh, did she?
Not two years in a row now let's go.
We got also the top.
- Light novels and number
three is a that time I go ring
cotton as a slime light novel,
which I've never actually read.
I've already read the
manga for this. Yeah.
There's a MOG is brilliant. Yes.
And there was the animal.
- Or the army was great. I loved it.
Yeah. Animals guys.
And then number two is a same one. The,
my next life as a villainess,
which were already established.
And then number one is a
sentence of a book. One,
some great lineup of serious. I'm glad.
I'm glad to send it to have
book one. God, number one,
because that is honestly, I'm surprised.
I didn't realize there were
that many people reading it.
It's a really refreshing because
no one's talking about the
anime, but like my next knife
has a Vanessa and a slime.
Definitely got a lot more
talk and discussion on crunch.
Although it was quite popular.
My next life is wellness.
Yeah. But I'm really shocked with the,
you are my princess results,
man, that really did well.
All right. Could you handle it.
- Again until December the eighth?
- You can get up to 50% coin
back on series that made it on
the list. So you can check out book,
walk at least down in
the description below.
And thank you once again to
book Walker for sponsoring this
episode. Also congratulations to.
I can't wait to frame
this a four printed paper.
- I can't wait to give this my naughty,
not even glossy paper mailers. Seriously.
It's just a PowerPoint slides.
I don't actually care.
- I had a great time making
it. I got a banger of a video.
That's all I ever wanted.
This is like that,
that student that turns into
homework five minutes before
it's like Jew, you know what I mean?
- Got it. I got it.
I get points with this. Right.
And it's like, Hey,
you've done your homework.
That's homework.
- Okay.
Well the power of yellowy. Thank you both.
Thank you very much to the
sponsor of this episode book.
We'll go back to the video.
So questions for you guys.
Is there anything else,
anyone you want to shout out
who has actually influenced
your own content or anything
about your own channel? Oh man.
I've, I've so many people.
I mean,
like I feel the majority of at
least making you sound like a
panel. I go right now.
- It's always a question I
get asked at every panel who
inspired you, Joe.
- I guess I'll go first then. Cause like,
I guess the first one I
want to shout out is Philip
DeFranco.
Cause I've been watching
films since 2006 and he's been
like, he's been the one content
creator who I've basically
followed for his entire career
because I followed him from
the beginning and you know,
he at, at the moment he's,
you know, does a lot of the
news and everything like that.
But you know, I, I started, you know,
I started seeing his progression
when he was like more
villagey and just talking
about stuff on the internet and
girls and everything like
that. And I like, he was,
he was like probably the
biggest inspiration for me. Not,
not as like for the content of my channel,
but how to approach YouTube
as a job. And as, as,
as a business,
like I probably would not be
here right now if it wasn't for
Phil, because basically during my break,
when I was at the BBC and I
was like trying to figure out
how to come back to YouTube,
like a lot of the stuff he said
before about how YouTube was
and content creators should
think about their career as like
a, as like a proper career
and how it's like broadened,
broaden their income and
everything like that.
I basically got a lot.
- Of that from a lot of the
things Phil had been saying for
like years. Right.
So here's the person I want
to shout out. Cause he,
he has been like a massive
inspiration for me and I took a
lot of what I'm doing now or
the way I'm doing now behind
the scenes from all the advice
that he's given over the
years. For me, it's like,
I dunno like my biggest
inspirations for like how to do
YouTube and like how to present
myself on YouTube weirdly
enough came from like all of the,
kind of the big OJI YouTube
is back in the day. So like,
you know,
the AFA mentioned like AVG and
like I used to watch a lot of
his stuff and like, you know,
basically YouTube is that
everyone knows like, you know,
Felix, obviously grumps, if
we're talking like actual,
like regular voguers,
like Ryan Higa was like a
massive ankle, right knee.
Like I used to watch like every,
he got a video that came out
just cause like it's really
good. And it's just like
such a like personable dude.
And like, definitely like the
way like he used to like vlog,
especially like where he would
just sit in front of a camera
and talk about whatever.
Like I took a lot of inference
from that because that's what
I do. I just come in front of
a camera and just talk about
whatever. Right.
Yeah. And like a, you know,
like smashed back in the day,
you know,
like they had like such
overwhelming power in the YouTube
sphere where it was basically
if you're on YouTube,
like anywhere before 2012,
like it was impossible
to not watch them. Right.
Yeah. So it was because like,
I guess like when I first
got into like YouTube burrs,
like I never really went directly
to like a niche that I was
interested in. Cause I
just wasn't aware of that.
So I would just basically
watch like all the big guys and
they influenced me, you
know, in small parts.
I mean like in terms of like
Anna CIB is probably like,
probably demo was my, probably
like my biggest influence,
but you know,
which energy of it hasn't
been influenced by demos.
So I think demos influenced
everyone in like,
at least a little way because
I was around before demo.
But I feel like it's even,
it's impossible to like think
of any two contents before
demo. Like, I mean like off the demo,
it's it all he changed the
field completely. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Come back demo.
- I cannot think of my
inspirations. I mean,
obviously I was watching
my own inspiration.
No, I know I've taken like, you know,
I've definitely been taking
bits and pieces, right?
Like definitely like pots of, you know,
Peter Popsie growing up,
watching him in high school,
watching him do bits and pieces,
I think from like a lot
of different people.
But I can't think of like any
one of top of my head that has
been like huge.
- When you watch so much
content, especially on YouTube.
It's like, it's not just one person.
Right.
Because otherwise you just end
up being exactly like that.
Exactly. I mean,
I'm sure we can distill down a
lot of our influences and you
know, take bits here and
there, but at the time.
- Maybe I can break it down and figure
out exactly which ones
really like gave him my style.
Yeah. It's hard to say.
Cause obviously I, I
pivoted my content so much.
I know there was inspirations there.
- And you know, it's, it's, you know,
it's not to say that like, you know, we,
we still get inspired to this day. Right.
Without new influences and
whatnot, like, you know,
I'm sure like the majority of the YouTube,
as we talked about today have
influenced us in some small
way. We have just listed
probably 90% like our influence.
- Today. And basically,
you know what I mean?
Just, just in this two hour.
- Yeah.
Yeah. Is there any one else
you guys want to shout out?
I've got a bunch of channels
that we didn't really like talk
about that I could just speed run through.
Okay. Let's buy an old gas.
No brakes. God Tia challenge.
Love, love, love all gas.
No brakes.
I showed you guys.
- Yeah. He's like the modern day.
Kassem G.
- Donna put Kassem G but more
political because Kassa McGee
was more like, let's just
throw a topic out there.
That's funny.
But like also castle actively
made fun of them in a good
way. Like have some GS
pulled install videos.
Yeah. Like some of the
best content on YouTube.
Actually. If anything,
maybe Kassem G might have
inspired me at the time. Like,
I really enjoyed his way of
how he would insult them,
but not insult them.
But honestly, he doesn't
really do anything anymore.
And now he's just an extra in
movies. Like the transformer.
Yeah.
- Was he? I don't even know.
You have to know what
he's up to now, but yeah.
All gas, no brakes.
What I love about him is that
he doesn't even need to do
much. He just lets the stupid
people do the stupid thing.
I think.
- Willing to go there and
he's friendly with them.
He gets them to talk to him
and it's really hard to do.
I think. And a lot of
journalists just can't get them.
He gets like, everyone knows.
He's just going to be nice.
Like he's going to show everything.
- Like some of my favorite ones were
when he went to like the
COVID party. Oh my God.
Just the biggest cesspool
I've ever seen. However.
- The time he goes somewhere,
somehow people bring up Jews.
- Like I dunno, like
he'll go to somewhere.
Jews.
- Get brought up for being the
problem. And it's like what?
The first.
- Is like sleep the lone man, hell.
- It's crazy.
And I loved it on a PO I think
he was on the history podcast
where he mentioned like, he,
the reason like his influences
that like I could go all
these places all around the world,
but the backyard in America is so crazy.
Why would you not want to document? Yeah.
It's so true. Don't blame him man.
It's crazy.
There's a guy called honest
guys who does like videos about
Prague. I've no interest
in going to Prague.
I've already been, but he just,
he's just so passionate about Prague.
- I love it. Talking about videos,
watching videos that
you have no interest in.
I want to shout out Ristic
studies who makes essays about
magic? The gathering.
I don't, I don't know a
single thing about magic.
The gathering. I do not even
know the rules of magic.
I've never played magic in my life.
I play magic a little bit,
but the way that he breaks down
these concepts in magic are
just so interesting.
Like I think one of my favorite
videos of his is he goes
through like the history of
like the rarest card in magic.
I like how much it sold for
everything in black Lotus or the
black Lotus. He made a video
on that and like how to like,
like how people like actually
verify like that these cards
that's cool. And then like,
cause he starts off
talking about not the heat.
He starts off, not even
talking about magic.
You start us off this video,
this video talking about rare
baseball cards and the history
of like how these like all these cards,
how these cards have sold for so much.
And then he pivots that into
magic and it sounds like a good
dog.
amazing.
Like he's a great con and
he's editing as God's here as
well. Speaking of magic, but
on the actual, like regular,
this is a channel I watched
quite regularly called Chris
Ramsey.
- I think I've Oh, is it
the guy who does the opens?
- He does. Yeah.
He's he's, he's like a
professional magician,
but he also has his own
YouTube channel where he,
he got famous off of like get
buying these like super hard,
like 3D puzzles and like solving them.
But he also just does these
like videos where he like,
he basically like he did the
train before it was a train.
He actually does like the
professional magician reacts like
magic,
but like he actually has
qualifications cause he's actually
a professional magician and
he like kind of like tries to
like, he obviously, you know,
magician doesn't tell
their secrets. Right.
But he like kind of reacts
to it and says like,
this is a good magic trick
because of this. And like,
he kind of pinpointed
in ways where it's like,
you wouldn't really be able to see a list.
You were in the same
field and like he's right.
And I don't know what
camera he uses, but Holy,
his camera quality is like red camera.
Like I want to know what
camera he uses the most insane
quality camera that I've ever seen.
- Obviously loved Linus tech tips.
So that video where he talked
about possibly retiring Blake
broke, that broke me as well.
You know? Like it's such a,
like such an honest video
and you just can't help it.
- Why don't, you know what that felt like?
It felt like leaving.
You felt like that talk where it was like,
your dad's just like,
so me and your mom are going
to break up and you know,
I know, I know it's confusing times.
That's exactly what I
felt like, man, like,
honestly it's not your fault.
Trust me. It's like, we were
just, we've tried everything.
If anyone deserves to retire
it's lineup, the man has been.
- Like a, a staple of
YouTube and he's been,
he's been on the grind, man.
He's been on the grind and
he's just like, you know,
it's obvious that his, you
know, the company's built up,
everyone just loves to work. Yeah.
It's just so great. It's so great.
Seeing people like he would
just see me who seemed lovely.
You could be the biggest
dictator at all. I don't know,
but he just seems like
such a genuine nice guy.
- Speaking of Linus,
we got to talk about his
latest collaborator too mad,
the mic off crack head of YouTube.
Like my love to his content
so much. But my God,
I go out there with ADHD, one
of his videos and I'm like,
my attention span is destroyed right now.
- Friend, who you have,
who you just can't introduce
to people like you're so funny
and I love you, but I can't.
- So he said,
he's the one friend that you'll
proud to know that he's a
friend of you,
but you're also ashamed to
say that he's a friend of you.
- It's a bunch of other
channels value select two.
I've just shown you guys a million times.
This guy does like skits and
he's probably the best skit
channel on YouTube.
Doesn't really good music.
Like January music as well, just so funny.
And he hasn't blown up yet.
He hasn't blown up insane.
And I've literally been like
touting this guy to everyone.
I know for like months,
like every time I go to
someone's house, I'm like,
give me the ox code. Yeah.
I'll put on a song. You've had no ship.
Yeah.
- Speaking of other skit channels,
I want to shout out
Britain, Nick, this is like,
this is like a channel that's
been like around for years.
Right. But he, he's also a skit channel,
but he's one of those videos.
He's one of those channels
that uploads once every year,
you know what I mean?
One video. Yeah.
And it's like a two minute skit.
Most of the time to five minutes gear.
But his skits are so densely
packed that it's like another
level of quality. Like every,
every scene in the skits
leads into the other scene,
perfectly. The writing is just
like, so top-notch, you know,
you know, when you see like a scene in a,
in like a sitcom or
something and you know,
it's gone through like a
hundred different rewrites.
That's the kind of the
quality I'm talking about.
But because he, like,
he's been around for like
nine years or something,
but because he only uploads
once every year, he just,
he just doesn't like that.
You can't do that on YouTube anymore.
- Right. Right.
I mean, I also, I'm sorry.
What's quantity, but cracked.
He's like that one friend
who like is just a piece of.
But then the actually funny.
- I don't know. I mean,
I do love that you'll know that
dad's complete con but then
she funny crack it. He
just does discord humor.
So perfectly such a good.
He is discord as a person.
You know what I mean?
- A guy who, when I
used to do prank calls,
he doesn't really give any views anymore.
It was called house hotel. And like,
he's so good at prank calling.
And he knows all the like scams
inside out really good way.
I was influenced by him
with your scam call.
I used to really like his
videos. And I thought I found it,
like,
I really liked how he dealt
with it and he would keep them
going.
There's a few other
channels as well called us,
the guy kit Boga as well.
He does pranks really good.
And there's a guy who,
God don't know his name,
but he hadn't said the engine Kohl center,
that video was insane.
And that was really.
- Yeah, there's, there's,
there's a lot of content
creators that I don't know their
channel name, but I
can name their content.
Like if I say, Hey, those two
Indian guys that built stuff,
obviously like critical.
- Well obviously we talked about like,
I feel like proceeded and
critical the same thing,
but like different content
they're talking about.
Like they do the same
thing essentially. Right.
But pro CD is like talking
about food and Adam and and like
meme and critical is just.
And.
- I feel like critical.
We could do a video about,
and he's like one of the few
content creatures that can
literally do a video about anything.
Yeah. Yeah.
Like he, like, he can,
he can make it like the top
10 massacres of all time.
And I'll be like, man, if
the Holocaust a number one,
I'm not leaving this video, man.
my favorite video where I'm just like,
this is a video of the only
critical chromate, which was a.
So it was so disgusting, but
so good at the same time.
You're like, I hate you so
much, but Dan, this is yeah.
- Another YouTube. I think
we've all watched is the,
you won't know his name,
but Q army Japan is what it's called,
but he's the dude who makes knives.
- Yes, yes.
Yeah.
Makes nice out of everything.
I got a smoke out of jello.
I comment on one of his videos is.
- I hate to be in a jail cell with him.
- There's a guy called virtually vain.
He also did prank calls. He
didn't really upload much.
He did one recently, but he was
like the God of prank calls.
You did like a great African,
like he did like African
dictator or something for calls.
It was so good.
But this man is that the
King of prank calls up.
Do you guys know sorrow TV?
- He doesn't have that. That
makes that sound familiar.
- Just the he's like the only
channel I like that does like
Reddit videos. Like when
he like reads a sub Reddit,
like all the other ones.
- Right.
Are you talking about the ask
Reddit videos where it's just
like this computerized
voice. I was just like awful.
Oh my God. This is like, whatever.
Whenever Sydney does
any makeup or anything,
I just hear ask Reddit this time.
I might be out those videos, man.
- Our TV is like, actually
like, you know what?
A video that shouldn't require talent.
She brings a ton of talent.
That's our team.
He's so good at doing voices
and like voicing the like
Reddit thing. It's like, wow.
- Everyone was just
dogs. Wait, wait, is it,
is it actually just the
same ask Reddit threads.
But like this it's like
a professional voiceover
essentially.
It's like voice to them and
I'm just like, man, they, they,
they leveled up. Their
voice actually got boy.
Nice guys.
- It's actually like a guy who's amazing
is like doing voices.
Like you're so good at
like, I'm a voice actor,
but I can't do that.
- It's like hearing like,
like Morgan Freeman or like
narrate and ask Reddit threads.
Right?
- He'll swap the voices really well.
Soak it with comedic timing, James.
He doesn't really upload anymore.
- Griffin is like a guy that does lap.
It's kind of sounds familiar.
He's the guy who does like
the one dude 50 voices or
whatever. He's like.
- Nana's shout out to Nana's
cause now this has been around
for light.
knows. Hell yeah.
- I remembered yanas back when she was,
she was like the daughter
of fortune and just,
just seeing her like debut,
like debut as a V Chiba,
like it's it was just like,
it was just like such an obvious choice.
I know you didn't think about
it until it happens. Right?
Like the VCU I'm just like,
that's the perfect matter.
Of course she wants to,
she was a beach you buy
before Vichi was existed.
Let's be honest.
- I was voice acting online
since like 2013, 2014.
And she was still like the staple. Yeah.
I pitched posting. Yeah.
And that was back then.
And it's crazy to see that
she's like peaking now. Yeah.
It's really cool to
see someone doing well.
Who's been around for so long
a node city obviously. Yeah.
Like circle tunes HD as well.
That guy just a move stuff.
- I really like how he
was basically. Cause he,
he can animate. Right?
He does. He doesn't need to animate.
And I feel like it's
better because of that.
You must see in his videos,
it's the guy who has like,
he he's basically like
an animation Youtuber,
but instead of actually animating,
he just like goes into
Photoshop and just like wiggle
wiggles, like your.
- Models around.
- Yeah. That, yeah.
Jenny Nicholson as well.
- Up. It's not jump as good as
the gaming Youtuber who like,
he was the first person who
actually did VR gaming videos,
but just made it like
he, he, like I said, he,
he has this perfect line
of like comedic analysis on
literally just like VR games. Right.
Cause I I've I've I've not
seen any other content creator
that focuses on VR games except for him.
And he, he definitely set the bar high.
Oh.
- Well the is cold,
but he's been at my
recommended a bunch of,
he like makes video games and
like he made like among us in
3d and he like remade full
guys in like two weeks.
They didn't insane. I call
them just to shut the comments.
We'll let me know that guys.
- Is there any one you think
is like a low-key Wiebe?
it's like, it's like these
last couple of years,
like people who we thought had
no affiliation to animate or
just like Yama we've forgot
Carson. Call me, call us.
Oh yeah. He is he's
he's not a low-key weep.
He's a, he's a full degenerate.
Come to Japan already cast.
Come on.
- Hang out with, to say
anyone we've spoke, you know,
good about on or we like probably can.
- I have to come on the
podcast? Yeah. Come to Japan.
Every like this,
this is basically just been
a video to be like, Hey,
these are all the people
we watch. Come on, man.
Man.
Come on up podcasts.
- Yeah. I'll pitch to you.
Not only do you get to
come on the podcast,
we'll take you around Japan.
We'll have some good time.
We could find.
- We've got drunk planning.
- Yeah. But I'm sure there's like,
that's plenty more
recommendations for you guys.
I'm sure you guys watching.
- I have a lot of recommendations
to go and watch tonight,
boys.
- It's probably like,
this has been like such
a dense episode of like
recommendations.
Like write that down right
away. Please slow down please.
- Just rapid fire recommendations. Like.
- Like I feel like we did gloss
over a lot of the obvious,
bigger content creators.
- Many creators that I was
already affiliated with.
So obviously ditis and Emily. Yeah.
It's amazing. I don't
need to mention that.
- We didn't mention our friends
because you guys should know
by now.
If I've talked to you
in a DM, that probably,
that probably means that that
means I already know you.
You know what I mean? And yeah,
I think that's probably a good,
I'm just waiting for the
comment being like, no,
if only they did this with anime.
- Do you guys actually watch that? Like,
cause I watched John super eye patch.
- I watched the cow. I want
to shout out beyond Ghibli,
beyond Ghibli does
amazing animated videos.
And it's, it's hard to describe like,
like an anime YouTube channel. Right.
Because that's what I do, right?
Like how do I, how do I,
how do I describe this
animal YouTube channel?
Basically he does amazing
anime analytical content.
Did a great one on recently.
I think, I think check
him out was pretty good.
I think they have a.
- Lot of misses, but when
they hit, they hit good. Yeah.
- I've got to give a shout out
to my boy shaves like, Nope.
Not going to last at times.
I'm just looking forward to
being on his digest in the kid
section.
Okay. I'll need you digest.
Which is a series a where Chaves, this,
this energy where it goes
through basically like some of
like some of his favorite
YouTube videos to do with like in
the anime,
YouTube is least favorite
least favorites as well.
And this is like the one series.
I've pretty much think every
anime, YouTube watches,
even though, even if they don't want to.
- I told him I'm like everyone watches,
everyone doesn't want.
- Every attitude of a secretly
wants to be on the good side.
- It's like, did I make it
onto the good one this week?
- The reason I like watching
it is because my taste in what
makes a good YouTube or like
what makes an interesting
YouTube video is so.
- Different.
- It's a good critic. Right?
You can just appreciate the
cake that he's doing and don't
give a about you if you disagree,
which is more often than normal. I do.
Yeah.
- Don't worry. Shaves.
I'll do more interview videos for you.
I feel like the worst thing
you can do as a critic is just
flip-flop right, right.
If people know your personality
and people know what you'd
like, they don't give it.
It doesn't really matter if
I disagree with your opinion,
I'm still gonna watch it anyway,
because I know what you like.
And I take everything you say
with a grain of salt system
and respect about critics is that like,
they're not afraid of the
backlash because at the end of the
day, that is their opinion.
Right? And it's like,
rather than flip-flopping
on your own words again.
- She's got to double down,
you got to double down
on Europeans being like,
I don't care.
- If the majority think
that this is a good video.
I don't think it's a good
video. These reasons, you know?
I mean, I've already,
I've already shouted out scam
Cambodia reviews before. Yep.
- I like he's closed Christian pants.
He's talks a lot about
LGTBQ and he's like,
he's just such a funny.
- Person.
His editing is kind of bad.
- But like, man, is he funny?
He's so funny. Like he's just great.
He's just bring such energy
to shift Tuskegee energy.
He's.
- Like the gay best
friend, everyone wishes.
- Yeah man, like if I
need a gossip session.
- I would want to have a gossip session
with crispy nuts, man.
Crispy, crispy.
Now.
- I'm recommended.
I know that like the positivity
is going to be that she's so
funny. She's so good.
And that's really the anatomy
YouTube channels I watch,
unfortunately. Yeah.
- I mean, you know, we,
we basically just did a
two and a half hour long
recommendation.
- Awesome.
Let's just jump right
into it. We jumped right.
- Today in awesome. I mean, yeah.
I think I've watched
Malana my YouTube channels,
but I don't okay. I don't
subscribe to anyone,
but if it appears on my feed,
that's normally means it's
like a good video that's worth
watching because like my, my,
my subscription feed for anime,
YouTube was is just Twitter.
Yeah. That's awesome.
- Him to watch the best of the
week that shade recommends.
And I'll be like, God, this is.
- Because I'll take a limb on it because.
- I clearly have different tastes.
- I respect his work on the lights. Yeah.
I mean he did two
ferrous Garn Legon video.
I did watch the two hour
things long, but Bruce Good.
I'll give him that.
The men did good. Voiceover was good.
- But yeah,
we should probably end this
video with a special thing
today, today in like, that's
all we're going to call it from
our trash taste.
YouTube Polacks you should
probably blow that out.
Cause there's a new dress.
I did not realize that.
That was just for a bit.
Don't worry. Just rip it.
Come on.
There you go. That's it.
It's an early Christmas for all boys.
Susan sent us a letter what's
she did it by this letter and
this one, we got a letter.
- John,
something you've done something
very few YouTube creators
accomplish.
You've had an astounding 100,000
people subscribed to you.
Trashed taste highlights.
That's some fine, fine plastics.
- Two in one baby two in
one the ultimate flex.
- 600 K subs on main channel to get it.
- Like what a quarter of a
mil on the highlights channel.
I appreciate that.
I was going to be up on the
wall by next episode. Hopefully.
- Trust tastes is now
sponsored by GE fuel.
This is my favorite flavor. Zero calorie,
dragon fruit punch thing.
I'm not really sure.
- My favorite flavor is the phase Berry.
I want to join faze clan please.
No, I don't.
I like I with your flavor.
I just like pink lemonade.
I have nothing witty to say about it.
It just tastes like pink
lemonade and I like pink lemon.
- So shout out.
So do you feel you can use the
link down below to get some G
fuel for you?
- We've also left a coupon
code down in the description as
well. So go check it out
will be a real game also.
Hey, G fuel, can we get
our own flavor please?
We want trash taste flavor
that fresh tasting flavor,
taste water, white
food, milk, milk flavor.
- T G fuel at them to let them know.
- Can we have a wifi milk
flavor please? Awesome.
Weaves need our representation. the game.
Where's the weed.
- Back to the video
conquers on a rant. Massive.
Thank you. Thank you.
- Shout out to our paid to do
our patron at these awesome
patrons. I've gone to my YouTube voice.
Now.
It's not even a gig.
It's just like generic light.
It's just like generic,
YouTube blogger voice that,
Hey guys, welcome to the video.
You see the ukulele music, these patrons,
they are pretty awesome. If
you'd like to support the show,
go to patrion.com/trash tastes
links in the description.
Also check out our
Twitter, our sub Reddit,
and also for the first time,
check out our Spotify because
yes we are on Spotify as well.
If you'd like to listen to audio stuff,
I don't think we've ever
shared it out our audio only.
But if you, if you hate our faces.
- Five audio only though.
I mean the keep popping up.
- You mentioning them, but I
should, I can't write it down.
I feel sorry for Mouton who
has just like insert like 150
PNGs of like everyone we've
mentioned in this video.
Shout out to YouTube who died? Sorry.
Sorry, not sorry.
Murder. You did enjoy this
video and you like some more
recommendations. Let us know,
but also feel free to recommend channels.
Pull over more time.
We're always open to checking
out new content. So yeah,
definitely. Let us, if you will.
One of the channels that was
mentioned, feel free to hit us,
hit us up in RDMS. You are
interested in coming on.
Yeah, definitely.
Hopefully you guys enjoyed
today's episode and we'll see you
guys in the next one. Bye.
- Bye.
(bright music)